hey everybody what's going on yeah I
mean you can turn the fan on if you want
I put the jacket on for a reason she's
down there looking up at the fan looking
at me why in The Fan off yeah because
she's like usually if you guys are
sitting here then the fan is like okay
I'm gonna turn the fan off yeah I mean
like I said I was freezing my ass off in
here earlier I don't know why
yeah she's looking at it now she's like
yeah that's it that's it oh yeah I got
it it's on
look at her face look at her face
laughs
yes it's cool
[Laughter]
she's a funny cat well I mean she's
she's very uh aware of like
um patterns and patterns and like
routines the routines and if something's
different she's always like what the
[ __ ] is going on like you guys are doing
stuff differently what you would
normally she'll run up to a plate of
food if it's not full and just look at
it and then look at you and look at that
plate fill that up you put you and then
you put the food in there and she goes
yes and then walks away for later for
later yes that's what I wanted yeah
[ __ ] hilarious
all right so hey everybody yep uh Happy
um Three Kings Day of the three kings
three wise Kings not the three not the
three dumbass kids yeah according to
them according to the hard jaguar and
the [ __ ] comment section today is a
big holiday in Mexico yeah so happy
holidays and uh he goes by the other
name Carnival he's the also the
carnivots on it's also asking so what's
up my honorary white Mexican
anybody who can make [ __ ] custom
[ __ ] homemade [ __ ] tortillas is
Mexican definitely honorary Mexican
um went down to the uh
redneck liquor store today and got some
Micheladas modella Micheladas yeah a
regular liquor store was closed because
their computer was broke yep so we went
to the red next door and guess it was
there all the central Americans were
there
I don't think all of them all of them
holy [ __ ] yeah the star was really
crowded you guys yeah yeah all of all
three or four there was like two people
yeah yeah
yeah to be fair it was 10 30 in the
morning so you have to be a serious
alcoholic to be at the liquor store 10
30 in the morning those are those are
those are Farm Workers they're that guy
was off today so he's gonna go down
there and hey get him some scratch
tickets and get him some [ __ ] Modelo
or whatever you know and uh I think
those are nicaraguans I don't know it
it's hard to tell who it is I don't know
dude they're all Breakaway Mexicans they
were all Mexican at one time before
Mexico broke oh my God that should be a
band name the Breakaway man the
Breakaway Mexican
before Mexico flew apart about [ __ ]
seven eight pieces
uh Zach says what's up all your across
the old [ __ ]
we're fine he also says uh so what's the
show's new redesigns supposed to
resemble absence it gives me that Vibe
you know what I wasn't initially
thinking that but I do like all of the
Aesthetics having to do with absinthe so
maybe I was thinking of that in the back
of my mind is that like a lucid
I did yeah but I mean I liked the um I
don't know I just liked the idea I was
throwing around the idea I said I just
want it to be black in one color I said
so it's either going to be black and hot
pink or black and like green yeah and
then I went with the green in the end
because I thought that was more for for
unusual for any of our new subscribers
who don't know Jenny was a corporate uh
graphic designer who worked for uh some
really big alcohol companies and lucid
Lucid was one of the ones that was owned
by a company she worked for you did some
some of their graphic designs I don't
think you designed that bottle though
did you no no they already had that
bottle but I did do some um like when
they did events and stuff like that I
did like some menus and stuff well I you
know what they still sell it I didn't
realize I saw it in ABC Liquor when we
were there like a couple weeks ago
um they've done a redesign on the bottle
I think I like the old design better
because it was like it was simpler and
Starker so black originally it was a
black shiny glass like a tall narrow
kind of yeah it had two neon green cat
eyes looking and Jenny had a bunch of
merchandise from them and one of them
was a black T-shirt
uh with them two green eyes she had one
over each Teddy she went around it it
was a sexy shirt a big old [ __ ] I
don't have it anymore well yeah it got
like a bunch of holes in it because I
wore it a lot I really liked that yeah
when it was new it looked good yeah it
was dark black it was like a tank top it
was like a spaghetti strap yeah yeah and
it had like two it didn't even say Lucid
on the front it just had the two cat
eyes on the tits and then it said Lucid
absent on the back yeah
and uh [ __ ] those implants were [ __ ]
just showcased in that [ __ ] shirt we
gotta have a photo of that somewhere
I wonder if I ever have a maybe I don't
I wore it a lot
uh hard Jaguar also said Jenny I saw the
Last Broadcast a couple years ago yeah I
did a review of that movie and I put it
up earlier
um gotta say it's a very good movie
considering the budget of nine hundred
dollars nine hundred dollars that movie
was made for which I also said on my
review I could not believe that the
movie was made for 900 yeah
um and he says those dudes must be salty
when they sell it to Blair Witch became
um from what I've heard I think there
are some interviews with them like
floating around and they might be on the
Blu-ray as well but yeah they're um
they're a little bitter about it but I
mean you can't really blame them to be
honest I mean they sort of had the idea
they put the movie out first I'm not
saying they had the idea first because
the Blair Witch guys were doing were
thinking about that like in the early
90s but they got the movie out first and
everyone was like eh and then 10 months
later like 10 months later Blair Witch
Project came out I was like oh my God
it's the best movie ever like you know
it's a whole sub-genre but then they
were like hey
um we're over here too we already made a
movie so you know what I mean so I can
see how they'd be kind of bad about it
was David Parker is David Parker in the
chat
um I don't know I was like scrolling
back to like read some stuff yeah Parker
if you're here man go ahead and drop a
comment in there I mean he's usually
here he's usually here but I wanted to
wait till he was here right getting
ready to go to the club but he doesn't
need doesn't isn't he at work usually
around his time and getting ready to go
to the club yeah yeah but like I said
it's only six o'clock so it's usually
coming home from work and then getting
home and getting ready to go to Maine
again because it's Friday
but yeah he began I'm gonna give him a
shout out he became a new Patron he
became a patron so we were very excited
major Patron yeah twenty dollars a month
Patron that's a major Patron yeah we
like that yeah
um John Smith said I like absinthe I
just like the uh anise flavor I don't
um
I'm not a big fan of absinthe I really I
like the whole
uh thing around it like I said I like
the whole aesthetic right well [ __ ] look
at this this necklace right here is an
absent spoon yeah
um you know what I mean I like the look
of everything having to do with it
unfortunately I don't really like asset
itself like I'll drink it but it's not
I'm not real big on that like licoricey
Flavor here's the thing I I like absent
as we know it but I saw a whole program
on it they don't know what absence was
supposed to with what it tastes like
um there was a
there were recipes out that supposedly
said this is what absent was
but it was kind of like Coca-Cola there
was a people had their own recipes and
they were I think there might have been
a couple different brands back in France
when that was going on
and it became popular because it was
issued troops at a war some of these
fresh Wars and when they came back they
still wanted it it was actually a water
purification thing you could put it in
dirty water because they didn't have
iodine tablets like they gave us but you
could put it in bad water and try to
sterilize it a bit and drink it but that
but they they got kind of addicted to
that flavor
it's a safe alcohol it's not dangerous
people are you know reading into it that
it's you know make you hallucinate or
whatever it was all a [ __ ] black
propaganda campaign by the by the French
wine makers who tried were trying to get
rid of it because it was so [ __ ]
popular
it was equivalent to like Cola everyone
kind of had their own recipe for Cola
but the main one was Coca-Cola and you
don't know what the recipe is
and they're on several recipes by now
absinthe was like that
it didn't taste like anise but they
didn't they didn't know what it tasted
like because all the people that drank
it are dead
um it got rebooted several times
uh in this one program a real one of the
top absence makers
got the offer of a sealed bottle of the
original absof that somebody still had
and they bought it for millions of
dollars
they had their main tester and all the
damn
chemists around to open this bottle
after they bought it never fight they
were in a bidding war with another
company
and they got their hands on that bottle
and tasted it they were just like oh wow
wow yeah
okay you know we were wrong it didn't
taste anything like ABS it didn't taste
anything like a niece
it just said it was a buttery flavor
buttery herbal flavor see I would
probably like that much better yeah and
um
I don't think they liked it when they
drank it I don't think they liked it and
it was a sealed bottle and it shouldn't
have aged out or anything they were
saying this is should probably how it
taste it was over 100 years old
and um
they thought they knew what it was but
they wouldn't say over in that program
because they paid millions of dollars oh
yeah they're like we're gonna make some
[ __ ] right and they wanted to replicate
that flavor and I don't even know if
they did that was the last I heard of it
uh I don't think they thought I I think
that they had I think they thought that
it was an unmarketable flavor
yeah maybe yeah because it was not
modern
they were just saying that yeah yeah
they didn't seem too jacked about it
they go okay
yeah and they were like uh man yeah they
were like it's buttery well what did
they expect that it was just gonna taste
like [ __ ] amazing anything like you
know what I mean like from back then
I mean I would have been like
it was acting it to taste like [ __ ]
bilge water it was a cheap product
purchased by the French government
to issue
the French soldiers who were deployed so
they could it was part of their regular
issue so they could purify water
that's where it started when that war
was over they went back to France they
kept asking for that
it became popular because they kind of
got addicted to that flavor it had a
certain flavor and they mixed it they
didn't drink it straight evidently the
guys who originally
who originally were into that
I think they mixed it with that with
water I think I remember I think they
watered it down
weird
but it was just something that they
drank at [ __ ] cafes and [ __ ] and tea
houses
Dave is here
what's up Dave hey Dave what's up we
wanted to say we wanted to wait till you
were here so we could say thank you for
becoming our newest Patron yeah thank
you for coming to Major patrons that is
awesome 20 bucks a month thanks yeah and
you totally didn't have to I'm gonna
give you a shirt uh next time you go
next time you go to the [ __ ] matter
kids I'll bring a shirt by for you
uh you're probably what
2XL maybe 3XL I'll give you something I
think we have some shirts yeah I think I
have some of those back there we got a
bunch of stock in there right you know
what I mean
um and I gotta get a new
screen for the new logo
yeah we got to make a new screen for
that we can print out here so yeah I
just have to buy um transparencies but I
can print everything from here now
because I bought a printer
so I could do that so I could mail stuff
from the house too so I could like print
out postage mango says Last Broadcast is
a cracking movie I really liked it very
much I've been wanting to see it for a
long time because I kept hearing about
how it got hosed by Blair Witch you know
what I mean because you know it came out
first and then got kind of uh shoveled
over but um you know I yeah I really
liked it I know some people didn't like
the end but I didn't mind the end Jeffy
art said watch Tales from the Crypt uh
yeah which we just did a review of or I
just did a review of not too long ago uh
and all through the house like the
Christmas one so why didn't Joanne frame
Seiko Santa for the murder of her of her
hubby talk about him this opportunity
right she totally could have done I mean
to be fair like the Santa what did like
jump in and kill her but let's start
string on her but she could have been
like wait wait wait before you kill me
let me just let me make a deal with you
I won't tell the cops you were here if
you take credit for like killing my
husband so I don't get in trouble for it
yeah see he says 2XL I'll see if I got
any back there yeah we might not have if
not I'll order some
yeah mango said to be fair Cannibal
Holocaust beat both of them to it yeah I
mentioned that in my review yeah because
Cannibal Holocaust came out in 1980 that
was technically the first found footage
movie but I'm just saying that
Last Broadcast was I don't it's not
similar to Blair Witch I mean it's
similar in the sense that it's still a
found footage movie and it's kind of
like has a mockumentary kind of thing
going on but the fact that it came out
10 months before Blair Witch and just
got totally forgotten about is really
kind of sad because it's actually like a
really good movie and like I said the
two guys that made it they made it for
900 and they completely independently
distributed it whereas I feel like Blair
Witch had like more money behind them
you know those two XL he's laughing he
goes I'm a big [ __ ] 5X
oh okay okay then we'd have to order
that
we probably can get it though if you're
serious I didn't think you're that big
yeah Jiffy shirts has Jiffy shirts okay
I just want to say Jiffy Pop yeah Jiffy
Jiffy like those corn muffins yeah
he's a big dude he's over six feet and
he's got some weight on him yeah
we want to [ __ ] with him he's a mountain
of a man yeah about 5x 5x they probably
have it huh yeah they could be serious
okay yeah they do you don't look that
big in person I would thought maybe like
2XL 3XL
yeah Jiffy uh Jiffy shirts has uh
everything up to six x I think if I
remember correctly depending on the
style they got all kinds okay he says
he's not joking he is a 5x okay okay all
right we'll order them
yeah I'll say yeah I can order that Mega
said uh talking about footage films I
watched a film tonight called the deep
house yeah we saw that we reviewed that
uh not too long ago not exactly found
footage but a very good creepy film
which is pretty much shot all underwater
yeah we we uh did that that was pretty
good actually
um Oscar says wanted to see uh the deep
house yeah we were we liked it
deathstream is a great found footage
film release last year I've been wanting
to watch that one too I've been hearing
like a lot of good stuff about that I
think it's on shutter so I'll probably
get around to it like this shutter just
added
they added a bunch of well they added
the Last Broadcast which is I was
excited about because I don't want to
see that for a while they added another
older movie that I've been wanting to do
for a long time which I will probably
put a review up of like sometime this
weekend maybe and they added a bunch of
um lesser known let's call them
lesser-known giallo movies
um and they're kind of like some of them
have really great titles like the police
are grasping at straws and like stuff
like that it's not that's not like that
but it's titles are kind of like that so
yeah so I'm gonna like maybe check out
some of those although none of them on
there are ones that I've ever heard of
so you know
okay he says he's got a uh uh the 13
o'clock shirt all right
I'll get you a uh a uh I'll get you one
of these
about one of these that would look good
on a 5x because it's a big image or like
I said please cons sure and I'll get you
one of these and then later on when I
get the the new logo made
I'll give you the new logo the new 13
o'clock below which which may be neon
green we'll see
I mean that's kind ideally I would like
to do green on black I think that would
look cool I think if we get the right
cut the right die if you get a bright
enough green it might work I think it'll
work because a lot of times we got red
before and it didn't really like it
didn't pop it printed out but you can
barely see it
uh Zach says I finally watched both
Knives Out movies and I think I just
found my new favorite movie series yeah
I really yeah Glass Onion I think it
might be on it's on Netflix Netflix yeah
so maybe we should watch that this
weekend you can watch it yeah because
I've been wanting to see that I heard it
was like I heard it was really good yeah
Ryan Johnson's Not a Bad director you
just don't want him around Star Wars and
he's kind of came out and says yeah I
was trying to give it a [ __ ] Viking
funeral buyer you know
you know he's not a good Star Wars guy
he's not traditional enough Star Wars is
a 1930s Style movie
action adventure kind of like old cereal
you know it's a copy of Flash Gordon
that's really what Lucas was trying to
copy because he couldn't get the license
to Flash Gordon
but it's just you Star Wars can't be
modern there's just something about that
about that story but he did good on on
um Knives Out I liked it I like knives
out a lot yeah I like so I'm like really
I'm really excited to see glass on yet
because I think that'll be cool and I
love love Murder Mysteries and Daniel
Craig's great in it even though his
southern accent isn't all that that's
all right good but he
yeah it's a little Foghorn leghorns yeah
it's kind of a stereotypical
high-class southern accent that probably
never existed it didn't exist in my
lifetime I think that that accent only
existed in Hollywood
well yeah maybe it did kind of remind me
like I said of some of those old Looney
Tunes cartoon video come here boy yeah
yeah
but you know but that's okay
Dave says when I'm around Jenny I suck
it in maybe that's why he seems smaller
hahaha
hard Jaguar said Jenny have you seen the
1899 series on Netflix not yet but I do
want to watch that because that's the
same people that made dark and I [ __ ]
loved dark oh my God dark was so good
um but yeah this one's weird like a mind
[ __ ] but you pick up what's going on
Fast still like the concept of dark
better and keeps you launched but yeah
I'll eventually get around to watching
that because yeah I really do want to
watch it
I really do want to watch that so I'll
get around to it one of these days I
used to have my own little Netflix but I
dumped it because I couldn't afford it
now you know what they started doing now
because I guess Hulu does this too
because I have a Hulu uh subscription is
that Netflix will let you have a cheaper
subscription if you have ads on it like
okay like if you watch movies with like
commercials well because that's what
Hulu's been doing for a while like you
can have regular Hulu which I which is
what I have which is like eight bucks or
something and then like you have ads
which like I don't care as long as it's
not excessive
um you know I can watch commercials you
know that's I can just get up and go pee
I don't give a [ __ ] so um so I guess
like Netflix started doing that where
they do a one where it's like I think
it's seven dollars yeah like 699 or
something like that but it's like you
know you watch ads in there I still have
the DVD service
for them do you really do they even
still I guess they still offer that
don't I have one of the DVDs in there
and every time I put it in an envelope
it's in the envelope ready to send back
it's Laura Croft Tomb Raider 2 I think
if I send it back they'll send me
another one because I filled out a bunch
of lists at a time and I don't want them
yeah so I just hold on to it
I'm surprised they didn't charge you
don't charge me no I guess they're just
like well maybe one day he'll send it
back okay but they probably forgot about
it yeah they're like DVDs yeah what do
they cost like a penny yeah or something
like that
that's just so funny I remember when
that was like such a big thing yeah
because everyone was like remember how
when that when that Netflix service
first started which I don't know if you
you remember but it started out as a
mail service like I said they'd send you
a DVD and then you'd watch and then you
could keep it as long as you wanted like
they didn't charge you like over fees or
anything like that and then when you
were done with it you'd send it back and
then they'd send you the next one that
was on your list that was back when
[ __ ] that was back in the 90s it was
back when Blockbuster still existed yeah
Blockbuster was still limping along and
everybody said that's never gonna work
nobody's gonna send this [ __ ] back but
everybody did like pretty much yep and
they're just like well if they don't
send it back they won't get a new movie
right you know so
there was an incentive for I mean there
was no there was no reason for people to
keep them really I know program on it
though a lot of that nay saying about
that service was actually coming from
Blockbuster yeah I imagine Blockbuster
well because they were trying to get in
on that [ __ ] too but they were too late
what they wanted was they wanted to be
something like a cable
where you put a box in your house and
then Blockbuster could pipe a movie to
you boy that's that would be some
[ __ ] that's some backwards ass
technology but you know
like a video on demand now [ __ ] all
all everything's like everything's like
that if you have [ __ ] old dinosaur
cable you can go over and you can see
where you can rent movies or even rent
porn and they'll [ __ ] blast it in
on demand you know and then charge it to
your [ __ ] account
well it's crazy though well because back
in the old days remember what a pain in
the ass what it was like to see a movie
and especially like somebody like me
that was like real into like weird ass
movies like I really liked obscure
movies and horror movies and stuff and
it's just kind of like if you didn't see
the [ __ ] in the theater then you had to
like wait a really long time for it to
come out you had to go to Blockbuster to
rent it they would all be out or
something like that and usually most of
the movies I wanted to see like
Blockbuster didn't have them or they
only would have one copy and it was gone
so it's just kind of like it blows my
mind nowadays that it's like pretty much
any movie you want to see you can just
you know with very few exceptions you
can just go on and go well I can either
watch it for free or I can watch it for
like three dollars I'm just like that's
incredible you know
it's crazy
have you guys seen the movie Eden log
strange movie that moves slow but uh I
couldn't not watch it kept me hooked no
I have not I have heard somebody talking
about that but I haven't like seen it
yet
uh Tom Sykes says who would rent porn
when it's free see I wonder that too but
I guess like it's still like a billion
you know billions of dollars industry so
obviously some people are paying for it
suckers no I'm just saying there's like
so much of every free at arto he was
asking uh com was asking you about 1899
yeah I already answered yeah I already
answered that question
one of these days I'll get around to
watching because I really do want to
watch that because dark was really good
and somebody's asking uh has anyone seen
Megan yet yeah I've been hearing a lot
about that one too and I even saw like a
trailer for it last night that looks
kind of cool but
we'll see I saw a couple of my horror
channels had seen it but I was like well
I'm not gonna watch their reviews of it
because I want to see it before I don't
like watching reviews until after I've
seen the movie you know what I mean
um
our Jaguar said dude I saw Coney in the
Destroyer yesterday oh yeah gotta say
Grace Jones is hot as [ __ ] yeah
what was weird about Jones is that I
always assumed that she was about six
feet tall that she was really big she's
not she's like five four five three
she's a little bitty thing but she comes
off as being really tall
yeah I always thought she was really
cool no she's about Sonia's size
okay didn't weigh anything she's a
little she's evidently pretty little
well I don't know about that because
Sonia is only about five feet tall maybe
well okay then a little bit taller than
that or four foot eleven maybe so she's
very sunny is very very short I think
she was somebody can pick it somebody
can look it up she's nowhere near as big
as I thought she was Grace
Grace was [ __ ] kind of ahead of her
time she was from Jamaica I think
yeah and uh yeah she was a trip she was
a trip kind of a kind of a goth girl for
her time
she wouldn't she really didn't play the
mainstream thing
Sean Smith said Grace Jones acts tall I
think that's what it is like some people
yeah he's huge yeah well she kind of
projects like power yeah you know what I
mean so I guess that makes her seem
taller she showed up on one I remember
when I was kid she showed up on on one
of those talk shows that might have been
it's either Letterman or The Tonight
Show
and she was wearing almost nothing in
the damn see-through gown
I think it was purple
I think you could see underwear maybe I
think I remember that dress and I don't
remember if they blurred it out but uh
or blurred out her but people were
[ __ ] just like outraged you're not
outraged kind of in a positive way they
thought it was hilarious but she just
walks in like that
and she said
I think it might have been Johnny Carson
and he was kind of like well you're not
wearing much because I don't she's like
I don't I rarely wear clothes really if
I go to parties like this yeah yeah
because you're just walking around naked
apart she's like yeah yeah she was she
was wild she was wild chick
in fact when she was married to [ __ ]
Dolph Lundgren
yeah I remember that yeah Tom Sykes Says
Megan is PG-13 which means it will suck
not necessarily but I mean that's not a
good sign so I'm just gonna say I'm
gonna well I don't know like
trailer for it and I was
like
um I don't know like I was kind of
ambivalent about it
I said they dropped some posters for uh
Ari Astor's new movie and the hype is
building for that one too yeah we always
got to see what uh what Ari Astor is up
to hard Jaguar said Jenny I saw X
yesterday won't spoil it I've seen it
um I haven't seen Pearl yet but I saw x
uh that was one horny little old lady
she was indeed what was this x I never
saw it you would probably like it about
a horny old lady well kind of it's a
slasher it's recent it's tie West
um and but it's set in the 70s and it's
like a bunch of
it's a bunch of people going out and
making a porn movie like to this it's
kind of like a Texas Chainsaw Massacre
situation where they're going out they
rented this Farm like to go make a porn
movie in the 70s and then like somebody
starts slashing them all one by one it's
really good I really liked it and they
made a prequel called Pearl but I
haven't seen it yet even though I've
heard like mixed things like some people
like oh I even liked it better than x
some people thought it was stupid some
people thought it was the greatest movie
ever so I kind of want to see that one
too okay Grace Jones is five eight okay
so that's that's average every time just
about well it's about that's slightly
over over average yeah I mean I'm sure I
thought she was shorter than that I
thought she's more like five five
I remember I remember being surprised
that she wasn't very tall
but I was like like I said I thought she
was like six feet you know
John Smith said I mainly remember her in
Vamp yeah she was great in that yeah we
reviewed that one not too long ago too
that's a weird ass movie with a big
[ __ ] Nicholas Cage
Zach said uh it doesn't she usually have
hairdos that are like three feet tall
yeah maybe she did back in the day yeah
I don't think she does that anymore
Jeffy art said my first time seeing
Grace Jones was when she was on the
PeeWee Herman Christmas special singing
Christmas carols in the playhouse it was
awesome and my parents were so confused
yeah [ __ ] I don't remember seeing that
I'm gonna have to look that up now
John goris the new Evil Dead looks a bit
lame to be honest I liked the Remake but
yeah I mean
I don't know that could go either way I
had you know I'm gonna say that I hadn't
I haven't seen the Evil Dead remake even
though I still like a lot of people
liked it even though you know when the
idea of it was floated people were like
oh my God it's sacrilege but a lot of
people did like it
so I haven't seen the Remake
um but I don't know about this new one
is this like a continuation of the
series is it like the same
because I know they did Ash vs Evil Dead
and that was like amazing if you haven't
seen that TV show
the thing about a thing about Grace
Jones we're talking about Grace Jones is
that Grace Jones she didn't she didn't
bend to Convention of her time she did
whatever the [ __ ] she wanted to do
whatever she was doing was left out of
left field
totally different she she knew how to
stand out
and she was just a model who could sing
and put on a show and she could act I
thought she was a pretty good actress
and um party animal
rich people liked her celebrities liked
her she evidently was real popular
parties and stuff
well she was just like unabashedly weird
yeah weird
way she was weird to do it well that's
what I mean I'm not I don't I don't mean
anything like insulting when I say weird
weird's a good thing
she was cool yeah
yeah and like
and she clearly just did not give a [ __ ]
and she was a bond villain yeah yeah she
played uh Christopher Walken his name is
Zoran I think is what the name yeah when
that would kill yeah yeah yeah just for
walking played the bad guy and she and
she was his girlfriend girlfriend slash
hit man he'd send her out to go go kill
people and [ __ ] it was the shoes
show up dress like a damn ninja and [ __ ]
him she could jump off the Eiffel Tower
and [ __ ]
well I mean damn parachute [ __ ] to be
fair if I was an assassin I would also
probably dress like a ninja yeah just
because yeah she was all stylish oh yeah
it looked like [ __ ] something
something [ __ ] Chanel would make her
[ __ ] Cartier would make her or
something I don't know well yeah you
can't just be like some
run-of-the-millage no no you gotta be a
[ __ ] Glam Master would she work for
zorin and that [ __ ] was a
billionaire right you know so it's like
yeah buy me a cool outfit yeah you want
me to go and kill people for you geez
you know
uh Tom Sykes said Grace Jones was in
Phantasm three that's right which I
still have yet to see really I remember
yeah that's right we have all the
phantasms I think we have on uh yeah on
ooh I'm sorry I had a weird thing happen
with my uh with my little question I
didn't remember that she was in that
yeah we have to like it's been a while
since we've seen it but yeah
yeah
yeah
um have you seen the trailer for
Renfield starring Nicholas Cage I have
not oh man
Renfield when did this happen
with Nicholas Cage is he playing
Renfield is he like an older Renfield
what do they give him the role because
like hey you ate a roach in that other
movie he's gonna cage you can be caging
the [ __ ] out no that's good that's good
that dude would be in any movie and he
doesn't phone it in he's his crazy ass
self well see that's what I said I you
know I respect that though yeah he
doesn't care if it's a shitty movie he's
just like what am I gonna get a paycheck
he's like am I gonna get a paycheck yes
then he's gonna [ __ ] go all in with
it man Mandy was a masterpiece I got a
[ __ ] God I love full size poster yeah
I bought you that for it it's silk yeah
Mandy where is that poster I don't know
what she did with it
it's not in here is it oh
I haven't seen that post oh wait no I
think it's in the man cave in it I think
so yeah I thought it was I think
posters you have in a man cave yeah he
has Casino Royale yeah that's not a
poster that's a picture
what are you talking about
no the um because the Casino Royale one
that I have is actually in a frame with
behind glass
yeah right here I'm just using the term
poster very Loosely all right don't get
all pedantic on it do stop it
um the other one was is your uh Blade
Runner 2049 one is in there that's in
there yeah and Escape From New York like
the green one with the with the
wireframe yeah it's got [ __ ] uh
Statue of Liberty Liberty in there yeah
that's a cool poster and uh I'm trying
to think about Mandy in there and then I
got that that fresette a painting a
[ __ ] conehead with that Sophie thing
yeah I got that yeah and
I think that's all I got in there right
now yeah
yeah I'm trying to remember because I
don't like it's down the hall from the
ring so I don't look in there all that
much but everybody knows what the ones
we have in here but yeah well I have a
couple on the wall behind here on behind
the computer that you can't see I have
one right there that is uh profondo
Rosso like deep red you know the Dario
Argento movie and I have a really cool
one from The Shining that's over there
and I have a Nick Cave one right there
like from a German Show from 2007.
and I think that's like most of the ones
that you can't see I'm gonna get a drink
okay
I also have I have an Edward gory one
back there but you can't really see it
and a couple from I think I have a New
York Ripper
over there too oh and I have one from
the John Carpenter movie Christine and
that's like behind that's on the other
side and from the 1931 Dracula because
you see that Frankenstein one I have one
like that but it's the Dracula one but
it's over on the other side of the
bookshelf so you can't see it from here
Dave says Renfield looks awesome the
dude from Warm Bodies is in it they
barely promoted Nicholas Cage
um
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna have to
like see this this looks like oh he's
playing Dracula in it
all right all right oh yeah that's right
like I remember somebody talking about
that that he was gonna play Dracula
and you know what's interesting of all
the Dracula adaptations that they've
done over the years which I'm sure
someone's counted but it's got to be in
the hundreds nobody has ever really done
one from renfield's perspective have
they isn't that interesting
so you know Hugo says my favorite Nick
Cage film is Conair I I barely remember
that movie I think I saw it maybe I
didn't well because
what okay so what ended up happening was
that I used to work at a newspaper and I
used to work with this guy named Al and
um he was like a real big movie fan and
he rented movies all the time pretty
much and he would always make a copy of
whatever he rented
um you know which it's not entirely
legal but okay so he would make a and
then like if so he would always like
loan them to me so I saw a bunch of
movies that I probably wouldn't have
seen otherwise because sometimes I was
just kind of like yeah whatever like you
know so I just like put it on in the
background while I was like cooking or
like you know cleaning the house or
whatever and so I probably saw it then
but it's like it's not like I sat down
and watched it though you know Oscar
says Christine is among the best Stephen
King adaptations yeah I agree and I feel
like it doesn't get as much love as it
probably should have and I'm not saying
that like there aren't some other great
ones like obviously Carrie is great like
dead zone is great misery is great but
Christine it seems like one of those
ones that kind of people kind of like
forget about
you know which is sad because it's a
[ __ ] it's a it's a great movie I really
like it a lot
um you guys should do a review of
thinner I've actually put thinner in the
patreon poll a few times but it never
wins I think it was in there like a
couple because they have because thinner
is on um
[ __ ] man I just saw the [ __ ] the other
day like uh
uh it's on HBO Max or
or Hulu or something like as I know when
I was scrolling through the movies
because they had like a bunch of Stephen
King adaptations and thinner was on
there and I was like oh yeah we should
do that but you know
uh John Malkovich was in Conair yeah oh
yeah yeah I remember that I remember
that
and uh they're talking about valley girl
I've been you know I've been wanting to
re-watch Valley girl because I don't
think Tom's ever seen it I don't know if
he'd like it or not because it's kind of
I don't know if I call it a chick flick
but it's kind of like more of a like an
80s New Wave romance I guess
but
and I think it's on I think that's also
on HBO Max oh you for you froze your
mind yeah going full on [ __ ] mix oh
and you got assault around there salted
Rim mug gonna use that
Modelo Michelle the the mango chili
the other one I have is the Pina
this is good though last time I had this
yeah those were good those are
surprisingly good it's just I was gonna
get one too but then like when we were
in there in the fridge and he was
pulling those out I saw this one I saw
this bad boy right here and I'm like ooh
I think I'm gonna get that instead
because these are really good I never
had the one and then the cane I've had
the one in the bottle yeah look at that
I poured that careful as a mouth I
poured it like a gentleman you poured it
like an [ __ ] yeah yeah they're saying
I poured it like I put that [ __ ] like a
gentleman no I'm I'm teasing you because
of like beer beer and board games yeah
well I'm telling that because I don't
know I'm beer in board games like the
the YouTube show
Matt usually like pours his beer but he
doesn't care like if the head is really
big so they always like oh you poured it
like an [ __ ] because it's like this
much beer and like this much foam
and he's just like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] so every time he does that I'm
always like oh you poured it like an
[ __ ]
yeah yeah I tried one now that's all
right oh it's good are you sure stop
complaining I'm not complaining
I'm not allowed to say no no of course
not
[Laughter]
so that's how that is
you know what all right you know I don't
really like mango
you know I'm not worried about it well
yeah obviously
he doesn't give a [ __ ] whether I like it
or not man that's good
you don't like that
it's all right like I said I don't like
I don't like mango flavor or stuff that
much
I liked the other one we got that had
that was pineapple yeah I got one
I like that but like I said I'm not you
know I don't really like um I got
another mug down there Frozen I don't I
don't really like that I got another
Frozen mug down there and I'm gonna salt
that rim on that one too when this is
done I'm gonna drink that drink that
other one
and hell yeah
I'll stand behind that one
carnivas line
I will stand behind that
that's a really good product
when I first bought it I said you know
they told me that was cheap [ __ ] but it
was expensive it was like three
something for the [ __ ] big old can
I said I got some crazy ass chat that
was 349 for 349 yeah and this one was
only 329. yes can and it's bigger yeah
so I got I said I got some of this
shitty Mexican beer and [ __ ] comment
whoop hold it hold on man [ __ ] Modelo
is a [ __ ] good Mexican beer it is
good very good and michelada
is like a cheery
Street flavor Street beer usually on Ice
I probably should have had ice in that
just turning beer into a mixed drink
I had
a couple months back and went to a
Mexican restaurant here which is
excellent all right
I even took pictures of what they were
giving me
and sent them to Khan and he's like oh
yeah that's it
and they had michelada but it was
hot sauce beer and hot sauce over ice
in a frozen mug
and them other guys some ranch hands
when they were all drinking it just men
you know just men men
during the day
drinking michelada it was good well you
know gotta get your fruit somehow yeah
well they didn't have fruit in that one
your vitamins it didn't have fruit in
the one that they were doing I'm just
joking yeah it was it was made with hot
sauce we got to get your hot sauce yeah
hot sauce just from I think I said that
okay
Tom Sykes says uh eg daily and valley
girl is a great reason to review valley
girl yeah she was in
wasn't eg daily also in
better off dead I want to say because I
know she was mainly a singer but she was
an actress too I remembered her being I
think in better off dead which is
another movie that I should probably
review with John Cusack from 1985 in
case you guys haven't seen that one I
always really like that movie I think I
saw it a million times when I was
growing up
Zach says uh you should review both
Basic Instinct movies one is actually
really decent and the second one is an
amazing disaster that needs to be seen
to be believed
I didn't even know they made a second
one to be honest with you
but I remember kind of liking the first
one but yeah it's kind of trashy but
there's nothing wrong with that
Mega said at the moment it uh in time in
the UK they were showing Michael Mann's
Manhunter great film Brian Cox Nails it
as Lecter that's another movie we need
to review because I remember really
really liking Manhunter I haven't seen
it many years but you know what I mean
yeah Ben said there was a Basic Instinct
too that's what I just did I didn't even
realize there was a second one
I mean what possible
I don't even remember what happened to
the first one like what possible
where could you possibly go with it
Tom Sykes said a single white female
Pacific Heights double feature would be
sick just saying
um yeah those are both movies that I've
been wanting to cover for a long time I
think I actually put single white female
in the poll a couple of times but
remember one that was the one with
Bridget Fonda and uh what's her [ __ ]
name
um
the chick that was in
Fast Times at Ridgemont High
Jennifer Jason Leigh he was also in she
was just in um the the the Quentin
Tarantino movie we just did hatefully
yeah okay yeah yeah so uh she played uh
this girl that moves in with this other
like as a roommate and turns out to be a
psycho like who starts kind of like
um like trying to be her
you don't remember that
very very vaguely I remember that it's
good I like it and forgot how hot this
was
because it's mango and [ __ ] chili
well yeah
it's good though I like it
almost like something from India
Bango says uh have it on in the
background yes it was a Basic Instinct
too curious movie
worth checking out for fun was Sharon
Stone in it I didn't think she was in it
I mean
no that should be in it she got locked
up right or that she killed she was
killed wouldn't she yeah didn't she get
killed I think she got killed with these
spoiler alert yeah well I don't know if
it's a spoiler alert or not because I
haven't seen Basic Instincts in a long
time so I don't remember what happened
to that
because they thought she was a murderer
right what the [ __ ] even happens in that
movie I thought Mega said yes she is in
it she is in it I thought she got killed
in the bathtub at the end no that was
fatal attractive Fatal Attraction okay
yeah that's a totally different that was
Glenn Close that was a completely
different person and a completely
different movie all right it's been so
long we just saw Fatal Attraction not
too long ago because we reviewed it
remember yeah
uh Tom Sykes said Tom talked about the
Pacific Heights film uh roach scene in
the Intruder film review yeah and that's
another one I've been wanting to revisit
I think I might have seen that in the
theater in Pacific Heights
um and I think I saw it once afterward
like on cable but I haven't seen it in
probably like 20 years and that was
another one I mean it's been a little
[ __ ] yeah it's been a long time since
I've seen it when did that movie come
out 90 something I don't know
I saw a lot of movies in the theater in
the 90s I kept hearing rumors that Eddie
Murphy was making Beverly Hills Cop 4.
Grand there said he was they were
shooting it in Detroit yeah that's right
that's right yeah that's probably he was
he was the last one he was the last guy
to tell me that recently yeah yeah they
said they're shooting it right now God I
hope that's good
it's probably gonna be good
I wish it was rated R I don't think the
other ones were rated R though were they
I don't think they were
I don't usually know I mean because
usually we watch them at home so I don't
usually know
I don't usually think about what they're
reading now where I don't think and if
the movie's good it doesn't occur to me
is that like what rating it is
because the last few Eddie Murphy movies
that came out I thought he knocked him
out of the park
I thought they were really good
especially uh Dolomite is my name that
that's a [ __ ] Masterpiece
they're good it was so good bought it on
Blu-ray yeah yeah
that was an awesome [ __ ] movie and it
made us want to go back and watch like
uh all the Rudy Raymore movies yeah
there's a bunch of them on to be matter
of fact gotta see them got us I haven't
seen them I watched uh Petey wheat straw
yeah yeah we watch PD weed straw the
devil son-in-law yeah yeah yeah we
watched that one yeah there's this
version of exorcism
no it wasn't Dolomite was it what was
the uh the one where he's the [ __ ]
Mega pant that comes out of prison and
it hooks back up with his hose that was
a [ __ ] great one yeah what was the
name of that one well that might have
just been the one that was called
Dolomite I think we should just call it
I think we watched Dolomite and then we
watched Penny wheat straw the devil's
son yeah because it was free on 2B like
I said yeah
Ben says uh Michael Keaton is a really
good villain
he is and you wouldn't think that
because
I think like in the 80s
well I guess before Beetlejuice
but it's Batman too but yeah he was
Batman too but I kind of feel like in
the early 80s he was kind of known more
for his kind of cuddly you know Dad type
of roles yeah I remembered him I think
what I saw him in Beetlejuice I
recognized him the most from like Mr Mom
you guys remember that one
do you remember Mr Mom uh no with Terry
Garr when did that come out 84
something like that I remember seeing it
on cable a bunch of times all I remember
from that was that there was something
to do with like a company that made tuna
fish and then also that Michael Keaton
made his kids grilled cheese sandwiches
by putting an iron on the sandwich and
like to melt the cheese it would work
that's what I mean I mean it would work
but it would make a mess of your iron
you'd have to like get all the grease
off it
you know what I mean yeah
um have you seen what Bridget Fonda
looks like lately no probably I have not
and
yeah that's I don't know why not I I
haven't seen her I was always on the
impression that she was a drug that she
was big into drugs
what was the movie that we just did I
just watch it her best friend was the
one where she played uh Lafayette Nikita
but she was really good at that
remember that that was Bridget found I
look pretty pretty sure what in La Femme
Nikita wasn't yeah the first of him
Nikita
the old one back in the 80s
I don't remember no it's good
hmm
if unless my she's being she's being
skeptical well no I just I just don't
remember maybe my memory is [ __ ] up
but well because I was thrown off
because I was like did I just watch
something with Bridget Fonda in it the
other day oh A Simple Plan der
yeah I just reviewed
um a simple plan from 1998 and Bridget
Fonda was in that she was great actually
everybody was great in that you would
probably like the movie A Simple Plan
Sam raymie directed it I had read the
book I saw the movie a long time ago but
I read the book recently like a year ago
so I wanted to re-watch the movie
uh yeah Zach says uh Bridget Fonda
wasn't in that movie see that's what I
thought
the film Nikita 1990
pretty sure oh she was in the American
remake America okay see that's what I
was thinking of well that was called
something else wasn't it maybe it was
didn't it have a different name didn't
have it maybe it wasn't the Femme it was
a different yeah I mean I knew that they
had done well see that's why I was
trying to think because I was like oh
they made an American remake but I
didn't think it was called La Femme
Nikita I thought it had a different name
yeah okay so you weren't wrong it was
just that it was called Iron Man yeah
yeah okay yeah La Femme Nikita was a
foreign film so I was like yeah she
probably wouldn't have been in that
you know
yeah E4 Mafia said unfortunately she's
unrecognizable these days she gained a
lot of weight
I think it had something to do with her
car accident yeah point of no return 93.
yeah yeah yeah that was a good movie I
liked it yeah I remember it being okay
yeah and I remember her was it that she
was in that movie singles
uh from the 90s what was that 94.
she wasn't a Reality Bites though was
she no
who the [ __ ] was in reality bites that
was when I had a writer right we're not
a writer and uh Janine Garofalo
yeah Bridget fond is fat wait can I let
me see unrecognizable I haven't seen her
in like many years
[ __ ] okay well
hmm
just doing his [ __ ] day Tom Sykes
says she probably
holy [ __ ] really yeah
well I'm gonna show you I I feel a lot
better about myself nowadays
yeah she turned into Jabba the Hutt
unrecognizable you would never know that
was the same girl poor girl yeah well
girl she did it probably in her 50s
yeah well you know 58 she's almost 60.
okay so she's a little bit older then
yeah
Tom Sykes says she probably packed on
the weight to look unfuckable to her
busted looking husband Danny Elfman so
she wouldn't have to [ __ ] him
I didn't realize
I didn't realize that she was married to
Danny Elfman I haven't seen Danny Elfman
in a while no he's he's not much of a
catch maybe back in the [ __ ] 80s I
don't know I thought he was kind of like
quirkily cute back in the day
but he seemed like a little bit of a
weirdo I thought like not so not a bad
weirdo but I just I felt like
um the vibe I got was he'd be like
really intense to like hang around
I got the vibe that he was a bad Weirdo
And I was I like to Oingo boy go I like
going to go a lot yeah I thought that
was a good band
no he always looked like somebody you
didn't want to keep take around your
children you know something like that
there's something weird yeah I don't
know I don't never got that Vibe but I
always kind of got the vibe that he was
like kind of tweaking all the time
like he always seemed like he was kind
of tweaking out you know what I mean
Victor says she's preparing for a role
for the past 10 years yeah she's
prepared for a role well I don't like to
get too down on people for like gain a
weight because you know what I mean it's
it happens
um she's an actress but yeah we're
supposed to be an actress
but I don't see I don't remember like
she was I I feel like her Heyday was
like the 90s you know what I mean I was
smoking hot and she was smoking hot in
the 90s and that point of no return
movie she was [ __ ] fantastic well
like I said I just watched the other day
I watched a simple plan from 1998 and
she was kind of playing a Dowdy or kind
of role in that but she was like really
thin and she was like really pretty you
know what I mean so and I feel like she
was in a lot of movies in the 90s like I
said she was in single white female she
was in singles she was in yeah she was
in town just goes to show you
when it comes to attractiveness weight
matters
it does especially with women
there's just less forgiving on women's
frames because they don't have the
muscle mass to support weight a lot of
them
um just
it's sad but it's true you know I mean
if I can uh there went her career what
are you gonna cast her as and then you
do cast her and nobody recognizes her
there's a lot of women that look like
that just walking around Hugo said she
was in Lake Placid yeah
yeah when did that come out was that
early 2000s mid-2000s
I don't know Dave says she needs to find
her mom's old workout tape I'm sure
there's a copy laying around yeah
I don't know why how I am
those [ __ ] workout tapes all of them
including the one that had Arnold in
them in it total scams
you can't be out of shape and overweight
and gain anything from those aerobics
well I mean I guess it's marginally
better than sitting on the couch but
it's very close to sitting on the couch
foreign
to make massive changes requires a
massive amount of work
in the human body
diet is one of the biggest ones all
right not eating much
you got to put yourself into a
fat burning situation
which is calorie restriction
when you get older it's harder just
because the hormones aren't quite there
so then you start getting into you got
to be hormonally optimized
that's a [ __ ]
secret code word for
testosterone and steroids
then you have to [ __ ]
do highly concentrated
anaerobic [ __ ] workouts which means
lifting weights that'll do it
and [ __ ] the more aggressive that
[ __ ] hormonal profile that you put
into yourself the faster it'll happen
and they're all doing it
okay I've come on here and said man I
really respect a lot of these actors how
they can change their [ __ ] body
weight so quickly they can gain a
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ]
mass or lose a bunch of weight and
become skinny like the dude from The
Machinist and everything yeah Christian
Bale no Christian Bale that's another
movie we need to review that was I
haven't seen it man oh it's so good
everybody says it's great it's so good
um I haven't seen it and then you have a
[ __ ]
um Tom Hardy
going from basically like
little cutie boy to [ __ ] Bane you
know zero to sixty as we saw how him
coming up through his movie careers you
know uh we did that prison movie what
was the name of that [ __ ] what was it
whether we did the print the British
Boston Bronson [ __ ] Masterpiece I
gotta revisit all [ __ ] Hardy [ __ ]
again I got him a half of it all right I
just really respect that guy's actor
he put the work in
but look man he's got the signs of
Androgen use all of men you have to
cheat to do what they're doing in the
amount of time that they're given all
those MCU guys the rock well the thing
about it is that they're not I mean
they're not doing they're not looking to
like sustain this for a lifetime it's
like look I have in a few months I have
to be in this movie and I have to be
this much bigger and I have to look like
this yeah they can digitally enhance
some [ __ ] but obviously well obviously
you need to like at least have something
for them to work off and then they
already know what the movie's gonna be
after that one and they're like and I
can't really look like that for the
movie after this so I'm gonna lose you
know yeah it's their job I mean they
have to and um Daniel Craig also yeah
man [ __ ] um he changes a lot
uh from movie to movie he's always been
fit but he's gotten jacked before and
then come down a little bit it is all
[ __ ] steroids this you know it just
is I I live that life I know what I'm
seeing they got all the signs for it
but that doesn't make it easy you're
still got to do it you know a lot of
people can't do it
a lot of people can't inject themselves
with things
they're scared
well until until you figured it out I
had to do it yeah
like because you were kind of weirded
out by doing it at first yeah so I did
it for a little while a little while
yeah until you
well no I'm talking about psychology I'm
not talking about physical I'm talking
about psychologically it took me a while
to get over the [ __ ] fear of
this is something that you have to
inject into yourself
it gives you like a [ __ ]
a junky feeling you know yeah
like oh man you're injecting something
it's not like you're [ __ ] tying your
arm off like in [ __ ] train spotting
or something
you know you're just I mean people that
are diabetics and [ __ ] like yeah do that
[ __ ] every day now I'm now I'm a lot
more um my grandfather was a diabetic so
I guess it's not weird to me yeah now
I'm a lot more scientific about it you
know I know that injecting is so much
more safer than eating than
going for pills because it's bypassing
the liver so you know really injection
is [ __ ] the way to go it's a lot
safer
but um
this year people Jenny's seen it man I'm
working on the band costume
I got the mask pretty much done I've
changed the mask up so it fits a little
bit better it's got leather yeah it
looks good I got the [ __ ] forearm
thing I'm working on yeah that came
today right yeah the the body armor came
and they sent me a [ __ ] large instead
of the medium that I ordered so I'm
probably gonna send that back I'm
[ __ ] pissed but I didn't really like
it so I'm gonna use a real bulletproof
vest that I have [ __ ] um a play
carrier that I'm gonna modify to look
like the one that they used in the it's
gonna
I'm like [ __ ] all this costume [ __ ]
I'm gonna use a real military
specification quite as well to do that
right so it's gonna look [ __ ] badass
because it's going to be real it's not
going to be a costume it's something you
could go to war in it's going to look
really good
Victor says I watched the whale
yesterday I don't know how I feel about
it I've been hearing like so much about
that and I kind of want to see it but I
don't know if I do or not you know what
I mean yeah
so
I don't know maybe I'll watch it and
then we'll kind of like commiserate
about it we'll see
uh John Smith said Jane Fonda's workout
tapes were really popular mainly bought
for other purposes yeah I'm sure Zach
says I love Richard Simmons so much
there was something about Richard
Simmons I mean he was just always so
positive I think that I can like um I
totally understand like why
he became so beloved of millions even
though like I said he was kind of weird
and everything like that but
he was just always so upbeat and always
so positive and he was just never mean
and he never like picked on people and
he was always just like really
understanding and I think like a lot of
people need that you know so I kind of
feel like it was you know like I said he
was a little bit he's a little bit weird
but
I don't know there was just something he
seemed like a genuinely good person and
I'm sure somebody will come out and go
no they found out he was a child
molester later on or some [ __ ] like that
because that's what always happens but I
just feel like he just always seemed
like a nice person
uh Ben said yeah exercise is great but
it's what you eat and drink that will
determine your weight largely I mean I
kind of feel like yeah you can't just
like sit around but
um
yeah what what you eat does have a lot
to do with and honestly like I hate to
say because I [ __ ] love to eat but
um particularly the older you get like
you really have to do like low calorie
you really can't overeat and especially
like the older you get like especially
me because I'm like 50 now so you really
really really have to watch it and I
can't and I was talking to my siblings
because I have three siblings and um we
were talking about this when I saw them
the other day and they were basically
like yeah we like the dudes like my
brothers they're like yeah if we go over
like 14 1500 calories a day you start
gaining weight and it's the same like me
and my sister are the same like you go
over a thousand 1200 calories which
doesn't sound like a lot and for some
people it's not but I go over a thousand
twelve hundred calories a day I start
putting weight on no matter what you do
so you know and it's the same it's just
I I just got really really bad genes in
some ways well no I got really good
jeans mostly but for a weight gain I got
really bad jeans for that you know
Jeffy art said uh Hollywood Dowdy isn't
real Dowdy yeah they call that Hollywood
ugly where you're like actually just
really hot but you have glasses on or
and you know your hair kind of slick
back
all right uh Tom Sykes said and yeah oh
yeah Tom should see the uh Darren
Aronofsky film The Wrestler yeah you
totally should you would probably be
really into that too Mickey Rourke is in
it it's very very good all right yeah I
gotta see that aronofsky's the [ __ ] Ben
asked if I take if I took steroids what
what is that [ __ ] you inject me with
I don't I don't know what it is just to
say yeah she does just not very much a
female female does this is what um
is going to be the basic for basis for
Bane's body armor
that's the real thing there's not plates
in it right now
it doesn't need plates for a costume
when you put hard armor in that or even
soft armor
it kind of distorts your figure
and it doesn't look as aesthetic like it
would from the movie we'll use that
there's some changes temporary changes I
got to do to get that look I'm going to
build another front
that'll stick on here
with Molly that'll look like the one
from the movie
and then this arrived today
that's Bane's
that's this [ __ ] real leather and
everything yeah
I'm gonna make a little bit of changes
so this fits a little bit better but
that's basically what he used
and then
the mask
the mask is pretty pretty much done
I had to change certain things
added yeah he's been working a new way
last couple days to adjust it
to get everything to fit I just hope
that by the time Halloween rolls around
you just that you don't decide you want
to be something else yeah everybody
every time we've gone out everyone's
telling you to be Ming the merciless
yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna make a
Ming outfit I mean you should have I
mean I'm sure that we'll probably have a
couple of different like
um
Halloween opportunities that you could
wear different costumes it's always nice
to have a couple different options I
think
Ben says the wrestler is great yeah
Mickey Rourke film yeah you would
probably really like the wrestler I
think I saw that in the theater actually
it's really really good
John Smith said I've eliminated bread
and pasta and I'm already seeing results
yeah that's usually what happens keep
cars low yeah like you can eat carbs
like but um yeah just just don't eat
that many of them you can't if you
without any carbs you can't even do a
workout because yeah you need carbs well
see that's why I don't like any diet
where it says well you can't eat this
that and the other you can eat anything
you want but just keep it really really
like uh yeah you just keep certain
things like a little bit like a retreat
you can go you can go on YouTube and
look at guys who are bodybuilders and
they say we're going to go on this keto
diet we're nothing but meat and you go
and they'll tell you how they feel
a month into it they feel like [ __ ]
and they said I've heard that they said
go into the bathroom's [ __ ] nasty
it's like [ __ ] out Grease
yeah there's no and they didn't feel
good on it and they had a lot of they
had a lack of energy
you evolved to eat a mixture of
vegetables and meat
there's got to be carbs in there yeah
you're an omnivore
as long as you don't overdo anything
right like I said I don't think down the
middle down to me yeah that's why like I
said any kind of idea that's why I'm not
really into these kind of like fad diets
like keto or anything like that because
like that might be good for short-term
weight loss but it's like that's not
you weren't designed to eat like that
over the long term I kind of feel like
you can eat
whatever like I don't think there's
anything that's oh you shouldn't eat
this or you shouldn't eat sugar or you
shouldn't eat that you can eat whatever
you want as long as you just like keep
it
balanced and like keep it under control
like yeah don't eat too much sugar don't
eat too many carbs don't eat too much of
anything and you'll be fine okay so the
question was
which is Gen on steroids
Jen is on HRT hormone replacement
therapy genus postmenopausal so she gets
replacement levels
of testing it's not funny I'm an old
lady yeah
we've had friends that have known us for
years and they're like you guys aren't
aging and I'm like I don't know I just
think it's fine we're not Asian you know
I mean we are but it's it's not the same
way as other people no okay
um for a woman woman in general
one-tenth of whatever a male dose is
that's what a woman can take within
reason but there's certain things that
they can't take
20 milligrams
a week
of injectable testosterone is great for
a postmenopausal woman
it'll keep weight off
it'll also produce a certain amount of
estrogen so because it aromatizes into
an estrogen so there's a so she kind of
has a hormonal
um profile of a much younger woman which
can help the metabolism move forward
uh process food better
and keep some weight off and
actually kind of help bolster things
like sex drive
which is intermittent on Jenny Jenny
doesn't want to put out I had to come in
here today and [ __ ] force myself on
this woman like woman brace yourself and
she's like no no no no I said embrace
yourself well it's the middle of the day
I was like I was in the middle I was a
man he's interested you know what I mean
I'm [ __ ] using all my masculine
charms and she's like nope nope I still
got some anyway but okay the uh so
you're gonna need you're gonna need
she's been on test
she's always on test
she Cycles off and on
the her main compound is injectable
Winstrol which is a very well understood
um DHT derivative
anabolic
um
very well known oh very well understood
from the 1960s and that's about between
5 and 10 milligrams a day this is that's
a few drops everything we're talking
about
a week we're talking about four or five
drops of testosterone a day a drop or
two of winstrol but she'll only be on
that for about six to eight months six
to eight weeks at a time
okay
Winstrol is
conus
is known for um first of all you get
great endurance the the average person
who the the the the the the main user is
endurance runners
but what it helps with is um a lot of
endurance and energy
and uh it has a slimming effect
now there's another one
that she was on a little bit
this is a long time back she was on a
little bit of Deanna ball
I think it was about two to five two to
five milligrams a day
that went on for a couple weeks and that
Deanna ball aromatizes into a special
kind of estrogen it's it's testosterone
derivative but it
helps build muscle burn fat
but then it aromatizes into a very
strong pound per pound per pound version
of estrogen
which can make women feel better all
right and give a little bit more of a
voluptuous shape so
she was on that for a little bit which I
got to get some more of that
I like it that's one of the best
testosterone derivatives
you can almost take it as a standalone
as HRT or hormone replacement therapy
this is originally what it was designed
for
but it's not quite testosterone so there
are certain things test you need test
for
I love the feeling of estrogen
I'm all man but I like the feeling of
estrogen when you have when you have a
high estrogen
um
count in your bloodstream
you sleep real well
it's neuroprotective which can which
protects your brain cells
uh your thinking is good
and you um
it helps it fights against things like
eventual Alzheimer's is another thing
that and it allows you to take other
other estrogen is better for your brain
estrogen is good for you because women
are smarter than yeah than dudes are
the thing is women mostly don't have
estrogen in them that's when they're
pregnant they have a lot women mostly
progesterone all right and I've been
I've had a lot of progesterone in me too
when I was on Trend trying to make your
very progesterate
progestergenic and it makes you [ __ ]
crazy and that's why women are crazy
well I don't know about it no I'm not
saying that but that's why a lot of um
well that's why a lot of women have uh
problems with birth control pills
because a lot of those are progesterone
yeah progesterone makes you [ __ ] nuts
I understand it when I [ __ ] was on
Trend I understood what women were
talking about with their periods and
stuff and [ __ ] do you see yeah well
the thing about it like when I was you
know I'm
maybe this is TMI I don't know yeah but
whatever I don't care
um you know before I went through
menopause
um my periods not were not bad
emotionally like because you know now
but I did know some women that were just
kind of that got crazy around this
because it does happen now I did have a
horrible horrible horrible amount of
pain like the first or second day so
much so that I couldn't stand upright
like unless I gobbled like lots and lots
of painkillers
um you know I just walking around like
that like I couldn't stand upright it's
like the pain was like really intense
but
um that I don't know it's just kind of
like I didn't get like the emotional
stuff though however
when I was on birth control pills not
when I was younger when I was younger I
was on birth control pills and they
didn't really have any side effects but
when I got a little bit older like into
my late 30s and went on back like I was
off birth control for a while and then I
went back on when I went back on I don't
know if it was a different prescription
or whatever it was that those made me
like insane
for a while you remember that yeah I'm
pregnant
yeah well pregnancy is all about
progesterone and and I had to go off
them like after a while because it's
like I was acting like a [ __ ] nutcase
all the time and I didn't like it I
totally understand it no I totally
understand but yeah I mean you get what
we have to [ __ ] deal with yeah
there's
there's uh channels out there with these
[ __ ] huge bodybuilders [ __ ] rough
tough [ __ ] that have and
they'll tell you Trend stories about
what it's like being on Trend when your
your testosterone levels will be super
high your estrogen will be zero okay so
you can't sleep you [ __ ] feel like [ __ ]
but your progesterone is [ __ ] your
progesterone levels are super high
and it makes you [ __ ] crazy all right
emotionally [ __ ] unsettling
it's not a good feeling yeah you feel
unsure yourself you're constantly double
checking yourself insecure as a
[ __ ] well I mean I use that all
the time anyway you got the testosterone
making you feel like a superhuman God
and then right next to it the
progesterone making you feel insecure as
a [ __ ] and you feel like damn
I'm vulnerable they're coming to get me
oh [ __ ] everybody hates me yeah God
I'm so [ __ ] up I mean I'm terrible
yeah you really had some problems yeah
but like I said I mean we kind of deal
with a level of that I mean I'm not like
I said I'm not speaking for all women
obviously but
me and like you know most other women
that I've talked to about this kind of
stuff
um we have a a version of that yeah all
the time yeah pretty much it's
progesterone
um but I mean to greater or lesser
degrees but I mean that's kind of the
thing like you do kind of feel like oh
you know I'm awesome but then on the
other hand oh I suck and like
everything's my fault and but you know
it's it's not a good here's it's
constant conflict and it's like you're
never sure of yourself you're always
second guessing always here's the weird
thing in the gym rat World though
[ __ ] dudes keep going back
to that and Trend quite regularly I
gotta go back on it [ __ ] at least
twice next year for the Bane costume for
Bae to keep warning me ahead of time yes
it won't last long he got a little I
don't want to say volatile because you
weren't like violent or anything really
but you were just kind of like I thought
[ __ ] you were on an emotional roller
coaster and oh everything was wrong and
yeah and I did kind of get the sense
that you were kind of like thinking that
I was yeah like she's gonna leave me and
[ __ ] yeah so it was so it was
stressful for me too because I kind of
thought like I I had Warner though all
the time I was just kind of like worried
I'm like oh my God can I do this without
him like misinterpreting it as so it was
like I had to like walk on eggshells
here's the thing the thing is I know it
was an illusion I just needed like
reassurance a lot because you're real
insecure about it yeah it's uh but I had
warned her beforehand this is how this
[ __ ] is okay so we're gonna see and I
didn't and I wasn't taking that much
that [ __ ] it was something powerful it
was something very powerful now they say
that you kind of get used to it you know
what I mean over time we'll see
we'll see it was kind of like climbing
the emotional Mount Everest it was when
it was over I was so happy like I said
Welcome to our world
I was so [ __ ] happy Trend cycle was
over I was just like God I made it I
made it Welcome to our world and we
can't escape yeah
if you're gonna make it you're gonna
make
tell you the same thing yeah she's like
Welcome to our world yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah
yeah oh yeah
yeah I'm like yeah I'm telling it blows
right I'm telling her all this [ __ ] and
she and I was like no I don't feel good
no you can tell her she could she'll
understand you could tell her okay I
didn't know how to cover and tell Jenny
you know whatever I was feeling at the
time it was funny because because all
that [ __ ] I was going I was afraid to
show a weakness
you know what I mean because you get
real insecure about stuff which is weird
because it's just kind of like I told
you and I think I told you this the
other day I was like in some ways I'm
not I'm not gonna say I liked you better
on that stuff because it was crazy but I
was like I said in some ways I kind of
did because like at least you were kind
of acting like you had like emotions you
were acting like a normal you were
acting like I wasn't acting like a
normal person I was acting like a [ __ ]
no no but I'm just saying well because
your normal State as long as I've known
you is you have this very like overtly
like Macho shtick that you have going on
she says it's a stick it well it is it's
not a [ __ ] I got the credentials to
prove it well no I know but I'm just at
well and see you got for like real
defenses well it's not fake no no I'm
not saying it's fake I'm just saying
that that's just kind of like your whole
deal and so like the way that you come
across a lot of times is that you seem
like you don't give a [ __ ] about
anything or you don't like having
emotions or are your because you're just
always like trying to project like not
like complete
strength and emotions
just that's just how it is that's right
but women when you were on that stuff
yeah I was just kind of like oh see you
actually do have emotions like down
there underneath all of your
Macho whatever it is no no no you don't
you do but the thing is is that you're
under the influence of different
hormones it's like being under the
influence of different drugs
I mean to a large extent whether you're
on the hormones or I mean it's still you
right yeah yeah that's still you it's
not like it's not like it's not like an
alien presence took over your body or
something when you're under the
influence of these different hormones
I guess you could say the influence
there was it the accent or the emphasis
is different right the answers well
because like I said when I was on the
progesterone birth control pills it was
acting like a crazy person that wasn't
like a completely different person I was
still acting like me but just like a
crazy version of me you know what I mean
like it was just an amplification it
wasn't like a complete replacement of my
personality or anything
Zach says uh outside of the autism this
is a while back I got behind
um I think I have real good genes minus
the flat feet don't feel bad I also have
flat feet so you know I don't know if
that makes you feel any better but yeah
I have flat feet too
so
thank you Katie thank you very much have
you guys heard of the dark pictures
Anthology it's a co-op horror video game
series that lets you control the story
I've I feel like I vaguely heard of that
but it's like that sounds like something
that would be like I'd be really into
but so maybe I should look more into
that I don't really play a lot of video
games tom does but you know I like
watching him play video games
I used to be at the video games back in
the old days but it's like now I just
feel like I don't have time to play them
anymore
John Smith said my mother was 40 when I
was born she started going through
menopause when I was a toddler so that
must have been fun how she didn't murder
me I'll never know yeah
um
that's the thing I know everybody's
experience is different I probably I
went through menopause late like at 48
something which probably about the same
age my mom did
um other than honestly the only things I
had happen
were hot flashes occasional hot flashes
which sucked but
that was about it I didn't really have
and I'm not like discounting like
because I know other people I knew um
like an older woman that I used to work
with and I knew her when she was going
through that stuff and she was like oh
my God this sucks so bad and you know so
I know that a lot of people have it a
lot worse than I did but
like we were talking about on Wednesday
night's show I'm
I for some reason I I guess it's I guess
I got lucky in some ways
is that I don't have things like things
don't tend to like affect me to a great
deal like whether it's illness or
whether it's you know a drug like if I'm
taking some drug for something or other
like I don't respond to things like all
that
over the top you know what I mean so
it's like I didn't expect like and
that's been since childhood
um you know I'd get sick
and it would be like
nothing like I'd be over it in a little
while even though even if other people
got really bad or you know people are
like oh I took this drug and it had this
really horrible side effect or it was
like way over the top and it's like I'd
have it and I'd be like hey it would
just be like that so it's like that's
the whole thing and when I went through
menopause same thing like yeah every now
and then I'd be like oh man like I had a
really bad hot flash and I was like oh
that sucked you know what I mean but
other than that I had nothing else
nothing but I know that like a lot of
other people did
if they're giving all kind of money
thank you Jeffy yeah it was like I know
I was scrolling down because I got like
way behind
um because I I wanted to comment on Zach
saying he had flat feet and I said I
also have flat feet
it's ridiculous
why fat feet are just ridiculous well I
can't help it that's my feet have always
looked like that
they're just feet yeah I mean I can
still walk around on him yeah my knees
are not great but you know what I mean
never happened
you know uh so what are you gonna do
thank you Jeffy art we all know that
deep down Tom's a sensitive Warrior poet
somewhere it's way deep inside there oh
stop it it's way deep inside there
[ __ ]
okay in the Jan what this is the
pineapple one pineapple okay so it's not
mango and it's not is it hot though um
it says Picante picante's spicy
so spicy pineapple but I had this one
before and I liked it yeah
see now that's good
but like I said it wasn't so much like
the other one
I didn't it didn't read as hot to me I
just don't like mango flavor that much
the the heat in the mango one takes a
while for it to pile up on you oh okay
so maybe that's what it is
it's a good product
yeah that's that's good actually real
good it smells nice yeah it tastes nice
I like pineapple anything like pineapple
is probably my favorite fruit pineapple
spicy pineapple beer
and a mug with salted rim
yeah the salt is is helpful no yes salt
[ __ ] sets it up so
that's good that's really good
that was another thing a long time ago
my doctor told me I should eat more salt
because my blood pressure is so low
do I did I tell you that yeah several
years ago because remember all that uh
fainting and like [ __ ] that I was having
yeah
um I have like ridiculously low
blood pressure I don't know why I just
do okay E4 Mafia what do you say eat
something he's laughing me about this
house okay Tom how do I get into this
testosterone thing do I need to go to a
clinic and see a doctor yeah or do I
just need to do a bunch of research to
watch YouTube videos will you answer
that question I'm gonna go to the
bathroom okay
first thing is
I have to know how old you are
knowing what I know now all my research
I probably would have went on in my late
30s probably around 35 38 around that
time
that's about the timer you're going to
need testosterone supplementation
I didn't know much about it I went on my
late 40s early 50s
and I had already lost a lot of
physicality you can go back and look at
me on the show I'd lost a lot I was thin
but kind of almost virgin on skinny fat
and I didn't feel good
um
so age has a lot to do with it
this way and the legal way
is to go on Google
in your search browser
just go HRT clinic near me and go search
and they'll pop up there's gonna be a
lot of them depending on what state
you're in I mean they I think they're in
every state
you go in there they're going to get a
blood test and they're gonna look at
your blood
if you're low and you and they're going
to make sure you're low probably
they're going to try to justify giving
you 200 milligrams of testosterone a
week
and something like HCG
which is a pituitary gland stimulant
which is good it's good HCG is good too
it's good it's a female fertility drug
but it when you give it to a man who's
on test it'll keep you shooting live
rounds let's just put it that way
you don't have to take it but
if you if you know what I mean because
going on tests is kind of like going on
birth control eventually you should have
shut down you won't have the sperm count
to get anybody pregnant which some guys
want that
but take an HCG
does things like you'll never get
heartburn again you'll [ __ ] uh you'll
feel a lot better you'll drop weight on
HCG
that's a good one
all right
now the thing is is if you start dealing
with clinics
your first month all those tests the
consultation their first month of
[ __ ] drugs and needles you're looking
at about 700.
and then it's going to be 200 a month
every month after that and it's going to
include your needles
your month's worth of testosterone your
month's worth of HCG
that's not a bad deal
there's a black market
if you have a VPN or you can deal with
cryptocurrencies
or if you're in a gym that has a lot of
muscle heads
this is another way
um you can come across test good test
you just stumble across it yeah you can
come across HCC then you can come across
all this other [ __ ] like [ __ ] Trend
and [ __ ] win
there are providers out there okay let's
just say the borders are open and there
are dealers out there that are [ __ ]
reputable that
that can make sure they have ways of
getting stuff to you
and a lot of these guys that are getting
this are [ __ ] cops and government
agents are buying it too and soldiers
so they won't stop
this is where pro at this is how pro
athletes get their [ __ ]
so they have a long career of strength
and this is good for you this is not bad
for you it's if you do it right and
you're reasonable this can extend your
life
uh and it's shown this over and over
again
example Would Be Jack LaLanne
Jack LaLanne lived into his 90s he
wasn't natural though
he was doing tests in anavar easily
he lived a long time uh
now some of the guys that got big early
there's certain rules
you only have so much gas in your tank
if you're a young man 16 17 18 and you
start banging up a bunch of testosterone
and a bunch of [ __ ] steroids and you
get above 200 pounds and you're [ __ ]
below [ __ ] 15 body fat and they're
like five percent body fat 240 pounds in
your [ __ ] 17. you're probably not
gonna live long
all right there's a bunch of rules
think of it like boost
on a [ __ ] car
you keep piling a bunch of boost early
on that car is not going to get a lot of
miles out of it
it's similar with this
but if you're in middle age
okay
you can use this stuff to extend life as
long as you as long as you
do not go very much over 200 pounds and
you're not going too far below 15 body
fat
that's the general and it depends on
your frame if you're a little bit big
you know six foot something you might be
able to do 220. but your your heart is
only so big
okay you take roids and [ __ ] tests
and [ __ ] like that your heart will get
bigger and stronger
to [ __ ] supply all those blood
vessels but you can't strengthen the
valves the valves are [ __ ] like
cartilage
so now you got this big powerful heart
[ __ ] popping like a [ __ ] to
supply blood to this huge [ __ ] body
and those [ __ ] vows are [ __ ]
flexing like a [ __ ] wearing out
you'll blow a [ __ ] you you'll blow your
heart well the thing about it is that
once you get past a certain weight it
doesn't matter if it's fat or muscle
um your heart still has to muscles blood
muscles worse because it's denser yeah
if you weigh
if you weigh 240 pounds of muscle and
you're under
15 body fat in other words you're pretty
[ __ ] Lane
that would be kind of like weighing 300
pounds of fat
all right yeah and if you're in your 50s
and 60s already that's not that good
that's a lot of stress on you yeah I
mean you want like as little stress on
you yes you want to be lean
15 or below and you want to be kind of
light maybe 200 pounds
now if you're a bigger frame person
you might be able to get away with a
little bit more but it's it
the fatter you are in other words like
20 body with 20 fat and maybe 220 pounds
you're probably not that much stress you
just can't get
you cannot become too [ __ ] jacked and
exotic looking do you get real freaky
if you're a freaky looking [ __ ]
you're pushing boundaries you probably
won't live long well you see how a lot
of those bodybuilders that looked real
freakish like a lot of them tend to die
younger heart issues and that's why
because your heart is only really
designed it's only designed for us for a
certain for a certain amount of work
what it has to do and the more stress
you put on it over the longer period of
time then yeah it's gonna give out and
the freakier your proportions
the more anabolic or steroid assistance
it's going to take
to hold you into that shape because the
human body cannot produce enough
testosterone naturally especially in
your 50s to maintain that shape
so the more [ __ ] you're on the freakier
you are and the older you you are
the more you're kind of burning a candle
at both ends it's a lot better
if you want to go
you look great
you're lean you're not too much over
[ __ ] 200 pounds you're not taking a
whole lot of stuff with [ __ ] you can
live into your 90s
that's what I'm doing as with everything
it's moderation moderation you can't
just like overdo yeah like a little bit
of [ __ ] is good but it's like you know
I'm kind of genetically blessed
I'm a borderline hyper responder I get a
lot of bang for my buck
all right I can take
a small amount of stuff and get a lot
done with it other guys don't respond
real well they gotta
yeah everybody's different right
now I kind of have a genetic propensity
to look the way I look right now as long
as I have the assistance I need that's
how I'm gonna look
I'm not going to push it much more than
this I'm probably only going to gain
another 10 to 15 pounds and that's it
I'm done
I don't have to gain anymore
my proportions are right
after then I will just do maintenance
and do things like perfect shape work in
small muscle groups and get things a
little bit more round but I don't need
to gain Mass once I got another 15
pounds on me
I'll be at about 200 pounds 205 pounds
around I don't need to any more mass
that's that's all I need I'm five six
14 body fat
[ __ ] um
187 pounds
I don't want to go much more over 200.
200 really
so that'd be good right there that's all
I need
I don't need any more mass in that
Zack says uh my mom didn't have
menopause till 50 and given she is
emotionally up and down even on a good
day well you can imagine
um yeah like I said I didn't have
anything too bad happen but I know that
some people have had really really bad
experiences
um like I said for a while like mine
took a while I kind of feel like they do
because there's that thing called
perimenopause too where you kind of like
started it's kind of like off and on but
I kind of feel like it really kind of
went into it like in when I was 48 or 49
which is about the same
that's about the same time as my mom but
I didn't really see any big
I don't know there wasn't like any big
kind of like
moment you know it was just kind of like
oh okay and then every now and then I
felt kind of crappy and then
I don't know it wasn't anything I don't
know if it's just me it's just like
stuff like that I just don't I just
didn't notice it all that much and I was
just like oh yeah I guess
I guess that's what's happening you know
what I mean it was like it wasn't really
that big a deal but like I said I'm not
trying to minimize other people that was
just me I'm just like I'm weird like
that and
I've had that like with pretty much
everything my whole entire life I don't
know why I guess like I said it's pretty
lucky
but in some ways it's not because
if
um I don't usually have to take
medication for things
um because I don't usually get sick
which is very very lucky but
um
on the off chance when I do get sick or
have to take medication for something it
doesn't work as well as it would maybe
work on somebody else so we'll say that
to you
but the thing about it too is that the
one time that I had like for example
surgery and they gave me painkillers
afterwards
I took the painkillers and they worked
but
I didn't need to take them more than a
day
on what when I had the surgery I only I
only took I like the boobs oh yeah so
man she sailed through it my first wife
was [ __ ] in agony I only took the
paint what I took the painkillers like
the next day
a couple days that was it two days and
then after that I was just like nah I
don't really need him anymore I was all
right she well see she already had big
boobs that's true so she had
room for him
my first wife was like olive oil she
didn't skinny he didn't weigh anything
and they put these big 650cc implants
that are 700 CC implants there wasn't
any room there she said she said it felt
like somebody was just stepping on her
[ __ ] chest she couldn't now it felt
like that when I first woke up from the
surgery at Lake crease remember we were
talking about that the other day because
we were talking about the anesthesia and
everything when I first woke up from the
surgery I was like oh man it feels like
somebody like some big fat person is
like sitting on my chest yeah but then
like um after I went home I ate a
sandwich I took a painkiller I fell
asleep and then I woke up and I was like
ah you know it hurts a little bit but it
wasn't that bad and then like a day or
two later actually I think I went to
work the next day yeah you did and I
drove a car
yeah 50 miles yeah
it was like a little my arms were a
little bit sore but I was like ah
whatever yeah okay so E4 Mafia he just
said he's looking to lose weight and get
feeling good again with HRT
okay if you're not cut if you're not
confident that you can shoot yourself up
and that you can get your own [ __ ]
online go to a clinic
that's what I did
I went to the HRT Clinic because I
wanted I didn't know anything so I
wanted to know what good [ __ ] felt like
and what was normal
so then later on I was I was with them
for about a year paying the 200 bucks a
month
made a lot of progress during that time
well because they did all your blood
work yeah because you kind of get to
know like what is supposed to be like
yeah so it was a good deal because then
I got to know what was normal
and what felt good and what good test
test felt like so then when you start
getting into the black market stuff do
you go oh no that's good test too or oh
yeah okay and then you start feeling
fooling around with other things like
Diana ball injectable Deanna ball
injectable win straw win straw pills
Dianabol pills and of our pills
and then you start getting this [ __ ]
like [ __ ] Tran uh meant I didn't do
mint yet I [ __ ] but there's I'm gonna
do it all
eventually I'll do it all just to see
what they're like
um
you'll you now have but what I'm trying
to say is is that when you're doing this
under the supervision of a doctor you
have a Baseline
so now you're confident in what you're
doing because you know what normal feels
like you're like okay yeah this is the
way test is supposed to feel like so
this is good and then you can kind of go
on yeah
once you learn it once you learn the
ropes you're and you start talking to
other guys oh you like that well try
this
and if you're middle age
you have you don't have any there's no
downside to it because you're going to
spend the rest of your life on test
anyway
so you're never gonna have to worry
about PCT or coming off of test
that's the reason why dudes are having
all these problems when they're young
they're teenagers they take all these
[ __ ] steroids and then six months
later they're fat as [ __ ] because they
don't know [ __ ] they don't know how to
come off of steroids they can't do Post
Psychotherapy they try to go back on
naturally produced testosterones from
their balls
and you're never going to match
what you were injecting if you're trying
to live off your balls is that it's not
it's like a girl putting huge [ __ ]
implants in and go God look at how big
my titties are now I'll take the titties
out why are my [ __ ] titties get small
because you took the implants out test
is the same way as long as you have a
lot of tests in you you can take a bunch
of steroids and it's like also why do I
have back problems yeah
[Laughter]
what happens if you take steroids it
kills your testosterone production
so when you come off steroids you get
fat
but I'm never coming off test
ever but not for the rest well that's
why you asked I got no natural Tech
waiting until you get older right you
wait till you get older because I got no
natural test to go back to I got the
test of a 50-something year old man
that's not enough
you're in the dying process
my test comes out of a bottle
and so I can continue to grow and to
stay youthful
and and lean and if you're on that you
might as well [ __ ] do steroids every
now and then because you can come off
that steroid and it doesn't affect you
because your test is coming out of a
bottle it's not coming out of your nuts
so there's no downside to it taking
steroids you just move ahead and then
you then you come off that steroid and
you're still ahead
so it's not the same as some guy who's
trying to live off of his nuts
you know you'll understand go to an HRT
Clinic yeah
and then hang out with a bunch of Gym
Rats who do this [ __ ] all the time
because they here's unfortunately you
got guys in their 20s
that are on test that will never make
tests out of their nuts and they will
live off tests that comes out of the
bottle for the rest of their lives
because they're also doing steroids
but they made that commitment in the
same way there are young girls out there
that made the commitment to have
implants that they're never going to
have natural titties it's going to be
fake titties from here on out because
that's how it is
test is the same way
if you want that body it's you you can't
have natural tests really
and this is the rock and all these
[ __ ] stars that y'all are looking up
at those [ __ ] are injecting
their testosterone
that's what allows them to take those
steroids and come off of them
and the rock is a [ __ ] fantastic man
big dude is [ __ ] great build he's a
little bit older than me I think by a
year or so he's either a year older or
you're younger I think he's a little
year older he looks [ __ ] great and he
knows what he's doing he's not pushing
it he can live like that for a long long
time he's not that big he's just very
what we call aesthetic
his proportions are good real good and
he's strong strong man
he knows exactly what he's doing
John Smith says uh there was the French
model Lily Ferrari who was suffocated by
her own implants that is not how Lolo
Ferrari died she's called
um no I wrote about her yeah in my book
and I wrote about her she answered my
crime in Memorial Website she got
murdered they think she was murdered
they're not entirely sure she has some
nice titties though big old fake titties
well that's kind of what she was known
for right yeah but she didn't she didn't
die like that she didn't die like that
she got another Ferrari uh actually did
a did a scene where she was um she blew
a horse
yeah did she yeah she blew a horse I
don't remember that but yeah but I'm
just saying she didn't die like that
they think that maybe she might have
been murdered yeah
yeah they're not really entirely sure
uh Tom Sykes says Tom and Jenny what was
the first scary movie you saw that
scared the [ __ ] out of you oh [ __ ] man
okay well could have been a little kid
yeah when I was really look you know
what okay you guys are gonna laugh the
the first three that come to mind
are uh The Shining which came out when I
was
eight
um
My Bloody Valentine which came out when
I was nine I don't know why that scared
me so much because it's not all that
scary but um you know that oh and
children shouldn't play with dead things
which I just watched recently and it's
it's good but it's kind of like I don't
know why it scared me so much but it
scared the [ __ ] out of me the only thing
that scared me when I was a kid that I
remember wasn't a movie it was a Night
Gallery episode called cool air and when
that man based on a Lovecraft story yeah
when that man came out he looked all
burned up underneath that [ __ ] bed
that's how I remembered it remember he
looked funny calories to scare the crap
out of it that scared the [ __ ] out of me
saw it on I saw it on television
the original the pilot episode of Night
Gallery the one with Roddy McDowell
yeah that one always great you know the
one about the um there was like a
painting where like the guy was like
head crawled out of the grave and was
coming and he kept looking at the
painting and like the guy that was in
the grave was like coming closer like in
the painting every time like it kept
changing ooh that freaked me out that
freaked me out so I shaved his head for
New Year's you're looking like Denzel
Washington's twin oh yeah I got a
[ __ ] post to post a video up on post
a video on your channel there man
[ __ ] let me see she's got he's got a
mustache though
okay
John Smith said first scary movie I saw
as a kid that affected me was the gate
the gate is so [ __ ] good I really
really like that movie and honestly I
think the gate that came out at 87 I
think
and that's so I was you know a teenager
by the time that came out but I kind of
feel like that's a good movie and that
would have been a good movie back in the
80s like if you had kids that wanted and
you wanted to get your kids into horror
because I know some people do
um that's a good movie to start with
because it's like scary but it's not
like traumatic scary you know what I
mean it's just scary enough like for a
kid to watch okay about the HRT clinics
once you roll in an HRT Clinic it's kind
of like being a membership at a damn
video
rental place it's kind of like being a
member of that [ __ ] Blockbuster you
got to keep going down there and getting
your [ __ ] or they can send it to your
house
every now and then you gotta do blood
tests I think it was every five or four
or five months and then you got to pay
for that that's like another extra
hundred bucks so you get sick of that
eventually you start getting into
[ __ ] black market
where you can get actually better tests
twice as much of it for half
so it goes from
two hundred dollars a month
down to about 50 bucks a month if you
if you know what you're doing well
because it's legal to buy over the
counter in some country in some
countries and then they and there are
other countries that have no problems
sending it here
under another name if you know what
we're saying but you got to know what
you're doing okay
um and a lot of times
you find these companies these companies
and some of them are Chinese and some of
them are Mexican you find these
companies uh through friends that uh are
gym rats
or people that are in gyms they know who
the suppliers are and they're not being
hunted down by drug enforcement because
it's not really considered drugs in the
way these are hormones and law
enforcement is buying these
okay
so they don't want to stop it
okay I mean they're not drugs drugs
they're not drugs drugs they're not
getting people high they're making
people strong make them feel better
which I mean you could argue that some
drugs you know but we've talked about
that before I'm just I'm a big advocate
of just like legalizing [ __ ] it's all a
scam in most countries that shit's sold
over the counter in Mexico you can go
that's what I'm saying that's right all
the pharmacy and buy all that [ __ ] yeah
it's just that people want their Cuts
doctors say hey I paid money for this
degree you're gonna pay me for this [ __ ]
an HRT clinic will give you all those
steroids they're just going to charge
you more for them they're like you want
Winstrol okay so you can do all that
[ __ ] legally they'll still
sell it to you they'll sell you all of
that yeah it's not illegal it's just
gonna cost you a lot more it costs you a
lot more than if you lived somewhere
else yep
where you can just go buy it over the
counter like you could like some [ __ ]
bare aspirin or something Trend balloon
was never intended for human beings it
was tinted for cattle
in some states an HRT clinic will
actually give you trend
which I don't understand that yeah I'm
not sure what states that's legal in I
think Florida Florida pretty much every
you can get it might be yeah you can get
along but I would it's the thing is is
that trend
is cheap and easy to make because it's
used in the cattle industry it's it
so you can get 10 milliliters of about
60 bucks which is that's more than you
want and it'll turn Tom into turn you
into a [ __ ] [ __ ] no don't say that
because it's like
you know you could be watching the
[ __ ] it made you emotionally volatile
but it's like that's not bad you'll be
watching the chick flicks and the
[ __ ] dog dies on the movie and then
you want to start crying is there
something wrong with that it's sad no
it's sad why is that something to be
ashamed of because you get emotional you
know I can't take it
but no see I
that is so this is
okay now this is what we're this is what
we're discussing I kind of feel like why
is it bad that you cry when the dog dies
because that's sad wait well what it is
I don't it's I'm not on anything other
than whatever judgments under normal
you're not under normal dude under
normal hormonal circumstances you just
go yeah that dog died that's it
I could argue in my experience
um you know you just like not caring
that the dog died or not reacting to it
is
is aberrant okay Behavior because I from
my point of view it is sad that the dog
died so you're reacting to the dog dying
is not unusual for me okay you not
reacting to it and be like yeah the dog
that's really sad that's more aberrant
to me than like actually I wish I had a
little cam I could take off look you
guys need to see Jenny's legs Jenny's
legs why are you like just I'm just
trying to [ __ ] zoom in what I was
gonna tell you do you remember okay
do you remember back in the old days
when we were doing the matinee show and
we would go to like three movies a week
which I canceled the AMC because I
couldn't afford to pay for it because we
were never going like it made me sad
because I still want to go we never go
though but we never go because it's
cheaper just to pay to see a movie now
so I just can't do it because I'm like
look it's like 25 bucks a month I can't
afford that [ __ ] yeah so anyway so I
canceled it the other day
but anyway remember we were going three
times a week and sometimes we would see
the trailer for The sad dog movie yeah
you know what I mean like no way home or
whatever the [ __ ] it was called
that trailer
made me tear up every single time I
didn't tell you because I thought you
would make fun of me would you I wish
you would I don't remember it and I
think actually I think that we would
have gone and seen it but I think we
went and saw one of those didn't we what
was it it was some Dogma the dog movie
I cried at that dog movie your dog is
incredible
and then well the shitty thing see this
is the shitty thing about being a girl
you know that that movie is emotionally
manipulating you yeah you get it on
purpose and they and that they're doing
it on purpose on purpose but it still
works and that and it makes me mad and
then like the fact that it makes me mad
like makes me want to cry even more but
also kind of you know what I mean it's
like it's a really complicated emotion
so it's like but I you know what at this
point in my life look I'm 50 years old
I see a movie where the dog or the cat
dies I'm you know if I'm gonna cry I'm
not gonna be ashamed about it because
that's [ __ ] sad yeah and honestly I
think that if you don't get sad about it
then maybe you might be a sociopath yeah
just gonna say
and I think it's like really shitty that
not that crying at a movie is kind of
seen as like something weird or aberrant
when really it shouldn't be because
you're just like reacting to a normal
human emotion and I don't think that we
should
I don't think that we should like make
that seem like it's weird or weak or
something you know what I mean okay
they're all thanking they're all
thanking uh thanking me for the for the
information and checking out the [ __ ]
local things and local
test clinics HRT clinics and PSY is
going to post a video of his new bald
head and if you post it in time maybe
I'll go over there and [ __ ] see it
and I'll play it on the show his bald
ass head
bald ass
Jeffy art said like I said deep down
Toms has a sensitive side way deep down
but they're another yes it's very very
deep down
very deep down E4 Mafia said dogs and
horses that die or get hurt movies make
me sad yeah me too and it's like
honestly
the trend lately it's like every time I
see a horror movie now and I kind of
feel like this has gotten worse since
I've gotten older and since we got
Pookie like a few years ago
um every time I see a horror movie now
and like a cat or a dog or something
like that like shows up in the horror
movie the first thing I say is
nothing bad better happen to that
[ __ ] cat or dog actually I thought it
the other day remember that um on Monday
when we did that haunting episode and I
said that they that the girl had like a
a parakeet or like a bird or something
the second I saw that bird
come up I was like nothing bad better
happened to that bird because I'm gonna
be really really upset nothing did the
bird was fine but I'm just saying that
it's like
and and it's weird because I still love
horror movies and it's like you can kill
all the people in horror movies you want
seriously did you cut them up [ __ ]
dude I don't care like do it the second
you [ __ ] with a cat or a dog I'm just
I'm I'm checking out I don't like it I
don't like it
I don't know why that is it's dumb but
you can even like seriously I've watched
movies where they kill like babies and
like little kids and stuff and I'm just
like ah
but cat or dog no thanks nope don't want
to see it
okay
[Laughter]
that right there
is Mexican testosterone
you can buy that's 400 milligram stuff
that's the good stuff
and you can buy this over the counter
yeah
right
and that's what you'd use
for HRT just so you'd probably for HRT
you inject 200 milligrams which is half
a milliliter there's 10 milliliters in
here this is about a
right around 100 bucks
so there's two months supply for a
hundred that's 50 that's 50 bucks for a
two-month Supply versus 200 a month
for 200 milligrams instead of 400
. so really if this could be four months
worth
for a hundred dollars so 25 a month
it's one quarter of the the U.S price
for HRT
do you tell me why the [ __ ] would you
want to do with the Americans
we live in a modern world where there's
internet and [ __ ] all kinds of
shipping and vpns
you know their their way of doing things
yeah right yeah
actually if you have a VPN you can uh
watch movies in other countries too like
on all the other countries streaming
services
because you know
uh a lot of the streaming services in
other countries like Netflix and other
countries and stuff like that have
different movies than what we have so
that's that's actually why I got a VPN
mostly so I could watch like shutter and
[ __ ] uh and uh Netflix and stuff like
that in other countries because they
have a lot of movies that we don't have
uh Oscar says Tom that's illegal here in
the states no it is not it's legal
I mean yeah it's not illegal you can
still it's just that it costs a lot more
it costs a lot more you got to get it
through a doctor
Zach says what do you think of people
who say they're empaths my ex-roommate
called himself one all the time but I
think he was compensated for something I
mean I don't know like from my point of
view I get what that like I see what
they're getting at but
I kind of feel like well empathy is a
human
emotion like I feel like everybody has
that to a greater or lesser degree
unless like I said you're a sociopath or
a serial killer or something
so I don't know what
special information you're imparting to
me by saying that you're an empath I'm
like oh so you're able to put yourself
in the point of like you're able to like
understand that other people have
emotions also I'm like well Norm like
every like every normal human should
have that to some degree so I don't know
why you have to like
I get it and like some people are more
sensitive than others you know that's
true but
I don't know I kind of feel like it's
one of those things that maybe people
are like trying to be more special than
they actually are but I don't know maybe
that's shitty I don't know
Trey just arrived saying hey everybody
hey how are you
Jeff yard says the movie nope has quite
a few things to say about the
exploitation of animals and by extension
the people who work behind the scenes
one of the reasons why I enjoyed it so
much I still have to watch that movie
I've been wanting to see it for a long
time it might be
I think it might be on HBO Max because I
remember like seeing I know it's on one
of the streaming services that we have
because I remember seeing like a thing
being like coming soon and it's like
that was a while back and I've been
wanting to see that because I really
like the [ __ ] uh you know trailers
for it if we kill if we kill um AMC
I gotta do that that will save me some
money I did already I went through the
notified me because well I just did it
like yesterday I forgot all about it
well I went through yesterday and I was
like dude I was like I'm really like you
know I'm really like hurting for money
so it was just like and so I went
through and I was like man I'm like
subscribed to this and subscribe to that
and it's like so I got words I have my
own Netflix I had my own like all this
so I just got rid of like a bunch of
stuff which will save me like 7 500. let
me play let me plug again we're looking
for new patrons
patronage went from like six hundred
dollars down to three hundred dollars
we're getting some back right now
but you know
it took a couple years for it to slide
but that 300 made a big difference so
we're looking for new patrons
and uh I know that everybody here on the
live chat pretty hardcore
listeners I think most of these yes most
these people are already patrons
um but you know we have some people that
only listen to the show [ __ ] recorded
which you know there are another time
zone that's totally understandable
so I'm asking y'all please help Jenny
out get us get her some new patrons and
[ __ ] we'll do what we can for you
um we just want to try to keep the show
going and keep yeah and like I said the
thing about it is 25 bucks a month it'll
make it I said that I might do fewer
videos but I want the videos that I do
to be more like I want to be able to
spend more time on them yeah you know
what I mean like the one that I put up
yesterday
um the highway of Tears murders that I
put up on my crime and Memorial one I
mean that was like 45 minutes long and I
spent a while like making that you know
like writing the script and like doing
all this other kind of stuff so I want
to be able to like spend more time
because I feel like I was I wanted to
get a lot of videos out
but the thing about it was that I
started to get overwhelmed and I was
like I feel like I don't have enough
time to really like delve into like and
make the videos as good as they could be
so I want more time to do the videos
maybe do fewer of them but do like more
quality how long how long we've been on
two hours okay it's time for us to do a
break we need to play some commercials
before we do that I wanted to go ahead
and reiterate what I said before
people asking me about HRT and [ __ ]
uh anabolic steroids
my advice is that first of all don't do
Trent don't start with trend
any [ __ ] you can go through all
through YouTube and
talk to bodybuilders about Trend trend
is not for beginners you do not want to
[ __ ] with that all right
you must at least be an inter
intermediate level to mess with Trend
you're not going to get much out of it
if you're brand new do the other stuff
first
oh I do not endorse illegal steroids if
you're going to get them get them
through your HRT clinic first
here in Florida all that stuff's legal
but it's legal through an HRT Clinic
okay yeah just go they'll give you all
that they'll give you all you got to pay
you're gonna pay but they'll give you
all okay there is a Black Market if you
get involved in that black market
understand know the difference between
good [ __ ] and bad [ __ ] and a good
supplier and a bad supplier
get involved in a gym
if you are under the age of 40 I don't
really recommend you getting involved in
any of that [ __ ] you you're if you're
young your testosterone levels are good
enough they just go in there and [ __ ]
work out and get [ __ ] pretty big if
you're a professional athlete you're
gonna do what you need to do
you could read in between those lines a
professional athlete has made a lifelong
commitment to be on stuff
and they know how to do it nowadays just
like
a young
late teens girl decides she wants big
old implants she's made that commitment
to have those implants in there the rest
of her life pretty much
it's the same [ __ ] thing it's just
that
hormones and anabolics have to be
[ __ ] dealt with with respect okay hi
there
never [ __ ] push the boundaries you
always want to be [ __ ] in moderation
under the supervision of a [ __ ]
doctor
or or a doctor that understands brocides
performance we're talking about uh what
do they call them [ __ ] sports
medicine doctor they they know about
this much more than a general
practitioner okay
general practitioner
sometimes they're full of [ __ ] okay well
I don't know about that they're just
they don't know much about practitioners
they're not a specialist they're not
Specialists so an endocrinologist or a
sports meet up with everything human
body is complicated right Andrew
analysis or a sports medicine guy they
know all about this [ __ ] A lot of them
take it
you go you go with them so that's my
advice
um
Tom psych says is Jenny following the
idea of student Idaho student murders at
all I had been following it a little bit
um I actually put it in the poll for
perhaps doing a show doing the main show
about it next week but we'll see how the
poll goes the poll went up this morning
so if you're a patron go in there and
vote for that [ __ ] if you want us to do
a show about it because I do kind of
want to do a show about it you know what
I mean yeah okay go ahead and play some
[ __ ] commercials wait a minute Tom's
and glorious bastard says we're still
waiting for Tom's Channel live from the
man cave with the Ross yeah I'm not sure
he's not gonna do that
he's not gonna do yet
nobody watch that anyway they probably
would but it's like you that's the thing
like you talk about you're like the idea
guy
you come up with ideas but you don't
ever like you don't you don't have to
actually like do the work to like make
them happen so they don't ever happen
you know what I mean
that's kind of the thing like you're
good at idea stuff but you're not good
at like following through I'm usually
[ __ ] doing other [ __ ] my mind's going
in different ways I'm I don't want to
say I'm lazy but I'm kind of like
scattered you know what I mean you are
kinda I mean I am too computer skills
are not that good that's part of it yeah
I mean and that's the thing like if
if you wanted to do it like he would ask
me to figure it out like to to do it
because I know how to do all that stuff
and he does not yeah and then I would
have her teach me but I'd have a problem
and then I would get impatient because I
hate having to teach people stuff and I
have a problem even keeping track of the
calendar
I don't have a really good sense of time
yeah so for me it would be very fresh
I'd be like wait a minute today is the
day and I gotta work it would be like it
would be like back in the old days when
I had to teach my ex-husband how to do
algebra
um I'd wanted to kill myself just
because like you know what I mean
because he wasn't getting it and it's
just like and I'm not you know I'm not
[ __ ] on people for like not getting
stuff but I'm just saying this like if
if you haven't got stuff like after a
little while it's like I lose all pages
I'm very I'm I'm a very impatient person
it's just I'm sorry that's just the way
I am but you know you you don't get on
the [ __ ] like right away okay you don't
pick it up right away I'm just I'm gonna
I posted a video of his bald ass head
right there oh my goodness there it is
they're not moving though
okay there we go yeah well what happened
am I talking you touched it I touched it
you touched it okay he's what
it's all waited out yeah there's the
bald head yeah
good thank you no you look good man you
look good yeah you look good it looks
good
yeah yeah see
you can work it looks good you can work
the bald head yeah like I said I wish I
could I'm taking over here but you know
what I mean
all right so I want you to do some
commercials we're gonna run some
commercials because I need another drink
my I finally finished this I'm making
another drink this was actually good
because it's like it took me two hours
to drink this big can I'm making another
drink and then I'll go and then I'll
where's your [ __ ] where's my [ __ ]
where's your [ __ ] I don't know what you
do with it it's right there it's right
there it is you moved it I didn't okay
all right so here we go we're gonna play
some commercials we'll be back in just a
minute
[Music]
[Music]
died in the despairing posters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
foreign
but yeah
foreign
so now I have
vodka and tea iced tea which that's nice
all right let me try to get back to the
channel Zach says Jenny are there any
cartoons with an art style you like
um I don't know I don't watch a lot of
cartoons except for old ones because I
mean if you've been watching any of my
scarce salon videos I did some Looney
Tunes uh things about Creepy Looney
Tunes cartoons and some of those
actually really do have some good
artwork but I don't know I don't see a
lot of animated stuff
especially not newer stuff
oh you know what
um if you saw the review that I did for
rock and roll
from
1983. I want to say that was I actually
quite liked the look of that it was a
little blade runnery
but animated did I show you that
which one rock and roll it's a Canadian
yeah yeah it has like it had like Debbie
Debbie Harry and Iggy Pop and Lou Reed
and yeah it was good I love that [ __ ]
movie you know what's crazy is that
just a couple weeks ago or a couple
months ago whenever it was like welcome
to the basement like one of my favorite
YouTube shows they actually watched rock
and roll and they didn't really like it
all that much and I was like maybe it
was I don't know if it was just me like
because I saw it when I was younger
um
I don't know I think it really holds
it's kind of like heavy metal yeah but I
honestly I liked it better than heavy
metal because I kind of feel like well
heavy metal was
I know well I like heavy metals because
there's a variety yeah it was it was it
was an anthology Anthology yeah but I
don't know there's something about rock
and roll that like always really
appealed to me
because it kind of had like a heavy
metal Edge to it but it was very I mean
it was very much like new wavy or more
like yes Post Punk yeah kinda and I
liked like the post-apocalyptic thing I
liked like though it was obviously very
influenced by a Blade Runner and I don't
know there was just something about what
I really liked I still like it I don't
and I don't know if that's just because
I saw it when I was really young or I
don't know I don't know
um Toms and glorious bastards you can
always make uh
cult in your backyard dude the the bald
Davidians
[Laughter]
bald Davidians
um Fire and Ice was good yeah didn't we
yeah we reviewed that not too long ago
did we not the thing with fire or nice
is that I didn't like it as much as
having I like this one I like it too but
not as much very Frank pizzetta I think
he was involved in that in that project
um
the problem was with it is that they
changed the story
in the original concept wolf Warrior
he was going after that evil queen to
kill her because that was his ex-wife
and the Queen's son was his son and it
made that made that story make a lot
more sense yeah I remember we talked
about that like when we reviewed it
because it did like give it another
dimension that it was kind of lost like
yeah
wolf Warrior was going back to [ __ ]
kill his son basically because he was a
creation of [ __ ] evil type of deal
yeah it was like a Shakespearean yeah it
was like it was kind of like some kind
of an Excalibur where [ __ ] where uh
King Arthur is trying to kill his
[ __ ] son with his sister [ __ ]
Morgana the [ __ ] evil witch and [ __ ]
wasn't the son's name Mordred more
Mordred I think is what his name was
that was a great movie same director
that did [ __ ] zardos yeah John Borman
yeah which I don't know if I ever got
zardos on [ __ ] Blu-ray did I I don't
think I did I don't think I did because
I think I thought I think I thought
about buying it for you I [ __ ] love
zardos
it's a better movie than you it's weird
for sure but it's a better movie than
you you might have been led to believe
hey man [ __ ] this that's some that's
some Alex Jones such a new world order
[ __ ] you know what I mean the the
oligarchs of the world decide to [ __ ]
wipe out Mankind and live in their own
[ __ ] green green [ __ ]
um
compounds and they had to starve out
[ __ ] Mankind and then they were even
trading dudes uh to to be executioners
for the human race and that was great
that was a great idea I mean it's a
bizarre good idea concept well that was
a that was came from a time you know in
the 70s where they were reading all
those weird
kind of globalist [ __ ] club of Rome
papers
about depopulation so in other words
it's going there with like [ __ ] uh
uh Soylent Green and
Omega man there's a lot of that [ __ ]
going on yeah which like I said I think
some of the context has been lost it's
been lost over time so it seems a lot
weirder nowadays like looking back Zach
says Tom yeah because he's asked this a
couple times but I keep missing it yeah
uh is it normal for a man who's an
alcoholic to have a second puberty so to
speak if he cuts down on drinking that
was my roommate situation he was saying
that his roommate
had been an alcoholic cut down on
alcohol and then started acting like
really emotional about emotionally like
volatile like all over the place and if
that was like normal
high levels of alcohol could be
testosterone suppressive
so it could be that
you're kind of test suppressed and then
when you stop drinking you start getting
better so it might feel like
some kind of puberty
but it's not it's just going back to
normal
you know reverting to them reverting
back to the main if you want another
puberty take [ __ ] test you will
actually have another puberty because
you're now but I'm not sure if you want
that or not but if you have you ready
for that you're gonna be a werewolf bro
you're gonna be the werewolf because uh
I love it warn everybody around you but
you get used to it you get used to the
new higher levels of test in your system
uh and then it becomes the new Norm
because I have four times what a man
should have
you know I have four times what a
[ __ ] 18 year old has most of the time
but that becomes the norm that's what it
takes to move the clock backwards
so he's like a testosterone like
superhero
I'm super human definitely that's what
we're gonna call you yeah I'm outside
the human range of what's normal
American Military 100 says Jenny how did
you react to the scene in the original
Halloween when Michael Myers killed the
strodes neighbor's dog
didn't love it
um honestly anytime anything bad happens
to an animal in a horror movie
I react pretty much the same way no
kill all the people you want leave the
animals alone I don't understand why
they hope to kill animals but you know
what I mean and honestly if you kill an
animal I think we've talked about this
before if you kill an animal that
automatically makes you like a hundred
percent less sympathetic than if you had
just killed people
if you went out of your way to like kill
a daughter I can't I told my friend
Steve I said man I don't know if I'm a
psychic that's like killing a baby yeah
yeah I told my friend Steve but you know
honestly it's like it was I feel worse
like if you kill a cat in a way like to
me that's like even worse than killing a
baby yeah
because it's about the same I mean it's
about the same as killer I mean but I'm
just saying it's like I'm gonna be more
upset I was telling Steve I said I don't
know if I'm a psychopath or whatever but
I [ __ ] [ __ ] ever caught if I caught a
little kid doing something like setting
fire to my [ __ ] cat
I'd set fire to that little kid I don't
give it I would too I would too that's
that poor gasoline and I don't even feel
bad about saying that no [ __ ] that kid
because I don't really see that kid's
Gonna Be A Serial Killer yeah we're
saving the world I was saying I promise
I was thinking like you're too dangerous
you're too dangerous to let survive yeah
you should not I'm protecting other
people now [ __ ] I'm
well I think the thing about it is that
him running away on fire like one that's
right [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're dropping fire man no I feel you I
feel like fire [ __ ] I'm telling you
stop drop and roll [ __ ] like I know to
a certain extent yeah like kids are dumb
and they don't understand what they're
doing but I'm gonna say I think that the
problem arises because humans to an
extent have like a little bit higher
realization of like what they're doing
and I kind of feel like animals don't
have quite that much so I kind of feel
like anybody that's doing stuff to an
animal like the animal doesn't
understand right yeah and it's like to
me look at Oscar should somebody shut it
down hey man or the cat a human death
and a cat no
no uh because you're a human you're
worse than an animal to me worse much
worse in some ways because you're
supposed to know better that's right and
if you don't right then you're right
I kind of feel like that's where I'm
coming you're supposed to know you're
supposed to know better and if you don't
know better then that means then there's
something to matter with you there's
something that matters here's something
else man [ __ ] I'm not I'm not one of
these [ __ ] friendly Bob [ __ ]
you know what I mean I came from an
infantry background as a as a young guy
I was designed to [ __ ] up dudes and kill
them all right and these weren't even
Bad Dudes they were just guys like me on
the other team
if you're bad I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
I'm enjoy it too does that make me a
psycho it might I don't care I don't
care what it makes me
I just don't
and if you set my cat on fire I'm I'm
all set you on fire well like now Oscar
says to a baby is supposed to know
better no no a baby's not supposed to
know better I'm just saying that
somebody doing something to a baby yeah
and somebody doing something to like a
cat or a dog is pretty much equivalent
about the same to me because a baby
doesn't understand a cat or a dog they
don't understand what you're doing to
them yeah and a cat is not a food animal
and there's a big difference and the
thing about it is that if you're a kid
like if you are eight nine ten years old
you've been [ __ ] old enough you can
talk which means that you have some
awareness right which means yourself
that puts you on the [ __ ] menu all
right I'll punish I mean you have to do
some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] for me
because normally normally if you're a
kid
under you know puberty age yeah if I was
real if you do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] it
depends on what the [ __ ] up [ __ ] is
yeah
I might have to go after your mama
because she raised you no no no don't do
that it's called might be group I don't
know I know I'm not going no I'm not I'm
not going how did you create this I'm
not going there because I no I'm not
going there because I believe in Mass
punishment though no no it works I'm not
going there yeah because the thing about
it is that look
I could have just like look I never had
children thankfully
nobody wants to have what's this nobody
wants to have like the world does not
have dealt want to dealt with a world
that had a kid that was produced by me I
never produced a kid but
um
I have often thought one of the reasons
that I never had a kid actually was
because I said what if I had a kid and
they grew up to be like the most [ __ ]
up person like what if they were a
serial killer what if this and then
everyone's gonna blame me you know what
I mean even if I didn't do anything
because the thing about it is that look
I've written and read enough about
serial killers to know
every now and yeah a lot of them have
[ __ ] up childhoods but some of them
didn't some had completely normal
parents some of their parents were
completely loving and it's like I really
really hate to
cast aspersions on the parents but like
look man we did like the best we could
the kid was just [ __ ] up we like we
couldn't do anything with it you know
what I mean and I get that because
sometimes
genetics gives you a bad hand sometimes
you have a kid and the kid is a demon
spawn and you can't do anything about it
you try to fix it but you can't so I'm
really really really reluctant to punish
the parents unless they know for sure
that the parents did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
okay if if you know that they were
abusive and all that stuff then that's
fine but it's like a lot of times look
at Ted Bundy he had like pretty normal
parents like some serial killers had
normal [ __ ] parents
and I don't think it's cool to like
blame them because it's like they
probably did the best they could with
what they were given
genetics does play A Part
it could be that you were a completely
normal couple so completely everything
was totally fine you had a kid and the
kid was just a demon's Bond you can't do
anything with that so it's like I don't
really want to blame I'm just saying I
don't want to blame
the parents for that because you know
what I mean so I don't want to jump to
that conclusion so I don't want to go
there with that
but I will say that once the kid is to a
certain age
if you are if you have if you're a kid
and you're a normal kid you had a normal
upbringing you had normal everything
and you get to 9 10 years old and you
are abusing animals yeah that's a bad
sign look what they're saying there
[ __ ] Tom's a glorious bastards you
read what he says yes it's absolutely
absolutely well you guys know that I was
raised partially in between Mississippi
and Brazil
you know and that's
that's Mexico
I said Ricky you can read what he said
what are you looking at right here Tom
you'll fit in just in any rural town in
Mexico Justice yeah Thomas bringing that
Mexican eye for an eye adjustment
exactly exactly well like I said
um and well it's also that that's the
way humans are I don't really like
the white man's version of Justice I
don't really think it's Justice I think
it's kind of artificial in in those
courts are too easily corrupted and they
involve people that weren't there and
they're trying to be cool calm cool and
collected and I'm gonna that's not
Justice you know not my version of
Joseph well that's not third world
Justice well the thing about it is that
that's not a tribal Justice right but
you can't just like I said you can't
jump to conclusions and like you have to
know a person's guilt that's what I'm
saying is that you can't just jump to I
don't really like this whole thing where
okay let's just have I [ __ ] caught
some dude setting Pookie on fire
all right that's it well if it was an
adult dude even if it's a kid that's it
I'm [ __ ] done or if it was a kid that
should know better well I'm not only
gonna kill that kid I'm gonna eat that
kid see Jake gonna [ __ ] that kid out and
then flush it down a toilet flush it
down the toilet
if you're old enough to know better yeah
then yeah if if then yeah yeah I'm I'm
right then I have no money if you're old
enough to talk then you you haven't you
had then you you're you have an
advantage well you can't [ __ ] talk
you're a sentient being you should
[ __ ] know better
you know if you're old enough to know
better like I said if you're like five
or something that's different but it's
like I'm just saying you're you're
getting like most of the kids that do
that [ __ ] are [ __ ] like 12. that's
what I'm saying once you get into like
seven eight nine ten twelve years old
yeah yeah you should Apple vanish you
should absolutely not we'll vanish your
ass you do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] at that
age
and I see you doing that
was like that [ __ ]
12 13 year old girl that was [ __ ]
cut that little [ __ ] boy's dick off
and [ __ ] strangled him to death and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'd erase that little girl
Maribel yeah a little British girl how
old was she ten ten or so she might have
been 10. I don't [ __ ] killed it well
like I said it'd been like something out
of The Walking Dead remember when they
had to go out and kill that little girl
she had a look at the flowers yeah look
at the flowers it'd been like that I
mean
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you thinking
there's something wrong there's the
thing well like I said it's on a
case-by-case basis because
some
and like I said there's a lot of thing
about like nature versus nurture
if you grew up in like a super abusive
household or something like that like I
get that but there is a genetic
component to that [ __ ] too we've talked
about this on our serial killer shows
usually if you get a serial killer not
always
but a lot of times to get a serial
killer or somebody that's not [ __ ] up
you have to have like a perfect storm of
somebody that has like genetic
proclivities toward that kind of
behavior
and then they're raised in a really
[ __ ] up environment and then like it's
a perfect storm of like terrible aspects
that like come to fruition but not
always because
sometimes you get somebody that's born
into like a perfectly loving normal
family and they still turn up [ __ ] up
anyway
and I don't know it's like it's a really
really hard thing to like because you
don't know you don't know like that
person might grow out of that [ __ ] later
I was just going this is sick of course
it's sick well we're talking about this
is an interesting life of course it's
sick this is an interesting
human beings are killer Apes that's what
they are you're an animal you're not
special God didn't make you
you're part of the animal kingdom you
only exist because people were [ __ ]
that's all it is there's nothing special
about you your parents [ __ ] probably
the back of some [ __ ] car and then
your mom squeezed you out you're not
[ __ ] special you said well these are
human beings I'm a human being too and
I'll [ __ ] you up
it doesn't mean anything
okay you got to stop these childish
Notions all right we're in the animal
kingdom
there isn't any really right or wrong
well there is but it's not it's there is
but it's it's not the right and wrong
we're we're told but what I'm saying is
that
we as a species
um you know we have evolved to
I mean you know we have empathy we have
other and like other animals have that
too Apes have that as well
so it's just kind of like when you
encounter
um a member of your species that is not
uh with the program
like that doesn't have empathy for
others like clearly
then that has to be dealt with them like
in some way thank you thank you
that has to be dealt with in some way
I'm not necessarily saying that I I
don't Advocate like oh let's just like
look at the flowers to the person but
it's like because everything is on a
case-by-case basis but I am saying that
a lot of times if you have a kid
who's and I'm not talking about a kid
kid I'm not talking about a toddler I'm
talking about like a [ __ ] 9 10 11
year old
that would
go and like hurt an animal deliberately
like I'm gonna go tie fireworks to a
cat's tail or I'm gonna go like you know
smother a dog or something like that
um that's a problem that needs to be
looked into and it's like if the parents
are like yeah we're gonna take that kid
to counseling it's like if they can sort
that [ __ ] out awesome but it's like if
they can't
something needs to be done about that
person because that's going to get worse
like later I had that dude that was
putting those kittens inside of Ziploc
bags and watching yeah we did a show
about that suffocate and then he ended
up no thank you killing his Chinese
boyfriend and eating his dick okay
[ __ ] when you have a dude it's never
good yeah never good yeah cruelty to
animals is always like the best that's a
bad sign and I'm somebody who hunts but
I was never cruel to any of those
animals
I just called them the way of [ __ ] a
predator would with a rifle shot and
then they were eaten there was nothing
about torturing those animals
you know and they had poachers they were
doing things like taking big trouble
treble hooks and putting them inside of
apples and hanging them from trees that
way that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] um see now no no no no yeah
that way that [ __ ] deer would be hung
up on that hook from a tree and they'd
come and kill that animal
that [ __ ] was not [ __ ] cool and what
you did was well I ain't gonna [ __ ]
you waited around to see who collected
that animal and you
because like I said anybody that would
do that to an animal
well probably do that to a person right
and poachers are [ __ ] scum all right
that's that's not a sporting and that's
not that's not the way the hunt was
supposed to be and the Hunt is about
food and about making as many animals as
possible inside your Paradise where
you're planting rye grass and [ __ ]
shooting paths and
you're only calling animals that have
already reproduced so there's been many
children you're trying to make animals
you're not trying to wipe animals out
and you're definitely not trying to
increase the sufferings of these animals
that's why I don't even agree with traps
like they had people that were using
[ __ ] traps I don't agree with traps
snares and [ __ ] yeah
done sporting is bad all right I don't
believe in that I saw that girl like
Hannah Barrow Hannah Baron I like her
[ __ ] but she was trapping little um
um
raccoons
and then getting them and killing them
to make a raccoon [ __ ] bed spread and
[ __ ] like that and I'm like man raccoons
are not really food animals they're not
crazy animals not let's not yeah let let
those things I kind of lost respect for
on that you know [ __ ] I'm not into
that
deer are food animals they reproduce
[ __ ] and but don't let them suffer no
no why would you
you want to give them a better death
than that they would give that they
would get in in nature in nature they're
basically eaten alive by Wolves that's
usually what happens to them
so a raffle shot is [ __ ] a lot better
than what they kind of evolved for they
have a [ __ ] high
breeding rate you know they make lots of
children and even in hunting circles
there's a certain hierarchy there's
deer that you shoot and deer that you
don't shoot yes they're too young
they're too you know yeah they're they
you know they make distinctions that's
like you know that's one that's like oh
that's a doe and it's like they still
have so let's not shoot that one because
she could still have when I came up I
mean you really weren't you really it
wasn't cool to shoot spikes those are
[ __ ] deer at two years old I mean
they've maybe they've reproduced it's
legal to do that that does have horns on
it nah man you want four point to six
point
yeah Middle East do you want one that's
already that's been around for a few
years
you know and you're yeah there's a whole
protocol right there's a whole protocol
right you can only shoot does on certain
dough days
and you're not supposed to be trapping
um
deer you can trap varmint
but traps don't know what they catch if
you step in see that's why I don't love
that my big end of this trip this
[ __ ] trap thing like I get it if
you're starving and you're out in the
woods
I still don't I don't like it snares
traps or you don't yeah you don't know
what's gonna fall into that and then you
see [ __ ] like [ __ ] like [ __ ] bear
and [ __ ] cougar getting caught in
[ __ ] traps and they're [ __ ]
begging for release their hands hurting
like crazy and dudes do let them go but
I'm like dude why was it trapped there
in the in the first place yeah let's not
stop trapping animals
you know and and like I said I'm not an
anti-hunting person I'm a Hunter
I grew up that way haven't hunted
recently I don't it's not a challenge to
me I I could buy food
but stop [ __ ] trapping and snaring
it's because you're just causing
suffering yeah yeah and it's not ethical
that's a last resort it's if you're
starving
yeah like I'll allow it if like I said
you're starving to death you live out
there by yourself but
they come out in the [ __ ] mountain
lions [ __ ] in a trap it's Paul you're
like man that poor [ __ ] animals yeah
they can get so stressed out they'll try
to chew their own arm off yeah that's
fine and the thing is is that they
weren't targeting the [ __ ] lion they
were targeted in Deer or some [ __ ] like
that you know what I mean but anything
can step in that so yeah it's just
that's it's just not cool you know yeah
I don't know random I don't like that
too Red I don't like that put your time
in go out there with the rifle and find
what it is you're looking for
yeah because then at least that way
you're gonna selected like [ __ ] right
yeah you're not just like like you're
making random animal suffer yeah for no
reason
that's [ __ ] up
you know and like I said it's not it's
not just that I like animals Better Than
People which you know maybe I do maybe
but you know what I mean it's just that
I don't think that anything should
suffer a un like needlessly you know
what I mean whether it's a person or an
animal
and I think that it's worse with animals
and you know kids and babies and stuff
like that because they don't understand
so anything done against them is like
worse in my opinion
Camp guy says I think you can kill 10
does and two bucks up here in Northern
Georgia
we must be absolutely covered up in Deer
I mean Florida where we are in Florida
like I used to see deer all the time
all the time
um not so much here but like where we
used to live in Sanford I used to see
deer every second third day just running
across the [ __ ] walking path
you know what I mean running across the
road whatever deer all over the place
but
we saw him in our backyard
American Military 100 he's in there
saying that I'm advocating for [ __ ]
lynch mobs and [ __ ] no no no uh well the
thing about it is that
the lynch mobs went after people that
mostly were already [ __ ] convicted of
some kind of crime and then you have
people that go down there and they just
[ __ ] pull them out of the damn
jailhouse and [ __ ] hang them
when you looked at the when you looked
at the big picture it didn't really
matter all right it wasn't that many
people it didn't make a big impact on
nature
um
I don't know I don't I don't love that
though because I wrote about several
cases in my book where
lynch mobs maybe
went after some uh yeah
went after submitted to people but a lot
of times a lot of times they were
already convicted and it just shows you
that a court will convict an innocent
person so I'm not a big but yeah but
the thing about it is that even though
and I'm you know I I concede that a lot
of times courts will convict it as a
person because that has happened
multiple times yeah
but I'm not saying that it's any better
for the public to be out there saying
it's like oh you know this guy's because
maybe that guy didn't do it either you
don't know that's what I'm saying you
don't know the court doesn't know the
public doesn't know so I don't think
it's a great idea
to
kill people which is you know you can't
go back on you have to [ __ ] have a
[ __ ] a more
you can't go back on that we have to
have a more nuanced view of what you're
calling the public
well no we have to have more of a Nuance
to the government everything I think
that's kind of like the problem is that
people have too much of a black and
white yeah governments and courts and
systems that you people rely on are
really just mechanisms of control that's
all they are but their purpose is to is
is to defend the oligarchs and the rich
people from you they're just trying to
stop uprisings that's really all they
are that's really all that's what that
it's only about that
those people that have based who are
basically funding and supporting these
systems that you call systems of Justice
they will never face those courts
they'll never even be in there those
things are only for you all right that's
what they're that's what they're for so
that's so already they just Target us
so I'm already skeptical okay
super rich people commit all kinds of
crimes and [ __ ] well of course never be
in there well if you make money yeah you
can get away with pretty much anything
they make those courts Break Stuff they
get all those they control all that [ __ ]
all right and it's just to keep you from
rebelling
has nothing to do with Justice now it
does sometimes bring Justice
they'll catch a killer and [ __ ] make
sure he's locked up but that's not
really what the point of that system is
that point of that system is to put
Terror in you
to keep you from rising up against
people who own you
that's all it is but well what I was
going to say is that the thing that's
complicated about all of this is that
reality is
complicated
um you know nothing is ever black and
white there's always mitigating
circumstances there's always this that
and the other thing and it's just kind
of like that's what's
Difficult about this kind of stuff is
that
you never know entirely like if I mean
if you are entirely sure that this
person did this that it was you know for
example like a serial killer they did
this that and the other you got DNA
evidence you got all of that then fine
like [ __ ] torture that person kill
that person would have like nobody cares
you know what I mean but
everything else is on
a spectrum and it's always like gets to
eventually gets to a point where you
realize that you don't you don't really
need right or wrong I don't really care
what's right or wrong I only care about
what's against me or for me that's
really all I care about if something is
good to me then I like it and if it's
good to the people that are around me I
like it if it's bad for us then I don't
like it
I can trust that everything else is
always some kind of word play somebody
spinning some kind of a narrative it's
not a word play it's just that I mean if
you got out of your uh head for a second
and stop being like
um your with your solipsistic World deal
I don't care
yeah I know you don't you said that on
Wednesday yeah
um
he only cares about himself well because
that's easier oh yeah yeah it's much
more efficient
it's easier to just care about yourself
well I know that they don't care about
me
well I know that the world that large
yeah they knew me they'd try to kill me
probably you know or at least half of
them would no one's trying to kill you
no they would go that no one started
that [ __ ] is evil so we're gonna
have to kill him half of them would do
that no one thinks you're evil no one's
trying to kill you
you're fine
but I'm just saying that
it's easier
to come at the world thinking like well
because I've thought this too it's like
it's easier to come at the world
thinking well nobody cares about me so
I'm not gonna care about it
and you know and that's just like the
end of it so I'm not gonna care about
anybody like the end so I get it it's
easier
but
I don't know it I get I get it it's
difficult
um but
every single situation you have to come
at it uh from like its own thing
you know I get
you know I write about True Crime all
the time I write about these horrible
cases I write about all this kind of
stuff
but
still
I still commit everything I try to come
at everything like as objectively as
possible
you know is this person
that we're talking about
you know what we were talking about
earlier like people that
we were talking about that dude that
like [ __ ] did the [ __ ] to the cats
yeah
I would just I would eat that dude they
had another dude we don't need that dude
in the world we don't they had another
dude they did a whole [ __ ] little
thing on him on uh
[ __ ] what was the name of that [ __ ]
Channel
oh man it's on YouTube what are you
talking about they're not sure exactly
who he was as far as I know took a video
camera set it up brought in a dog and
took all her puppies and he was slicing
her puppies up in front of the dog [ __ ]
the sliced puppies and then made that
dog eat her the gut wait is that real
yeah and then he had a video and then he
after he killed all that little that
dog's puppies he then beat that dog to
death with something and that was um
okay so like if that dude is real oh I
killed that dude and all that stuff yeah
I yeah I would eat that dude yeah and
[ __ ] that dude out [ __ ] um I would
kill that dude yeah make a stew yeah and
that dog's trying to eat him and then
[ __ ] him out that dog's trying to help
her puppies while he's slicing those
puppies up right [ __ ] knives people
that would do [ __ ] like that yeah y'all
don't need to be in there you know so
then that's what I'm saying you got
something [ __ ] going oh no you
can't no no no no no no no no I would
[ __ ] that dude up I was [ __ ] that dude
look and if nobody knew about it then
what happens happens well that's what
I'm saying you know but [ __ ] that dude
look
and he's [ __ ] [ __ ] the dead
puppies and [ __ ] and [ __ ] throwing it
to them like I said if that was real you
can't let it do like that just walk
around if that was real it is real
there's the guys
yeah by the name of the damn video wait
a minute just because there's video
doesn't mean it's real no it's real
they're looking for the dude
if that was real
then that dude should be found yeah
and I don't I don't think it was this
country
like I said if I found that dude
sure yeah I would kill that dude cut
that dude up
make him into a stew eat that dude [ __ ]
that dude Keith you still on there man
what was the name of that channel where
you uh because
like y'all like somebody like that that
that yeah you you have
um basically
you you've
you don't have any right to like uh
involve yourself with the rest of us all
right yeah you are not a human anymore
at that but you were lower than an
animal you were lower than anything
so it's like I'm
I don't have any problem like if they
know that that's you then yeah
bye yeah [ __ ] Keith Keith was on
there murder Hornets so I'm talking
about murder hardness for a second he
showed me this channel it was on YouTube
he had a bunch of cartel killings
and uh
murder horn is [ __ ] he's on that
Mexican border he goes down to Mexico
all the time
sending me [ __ ]
weird ass clips of [ __ ] the cartels
keeping dudes alive with IVs and stuff
and just cutting them apart to where
there was just nothing left but just
like a skeleton looked like a skeleton
with internal organs in the middle and
like eyes and they're [ __ ] showing
the guy what he looked like as they
vivisected him
and that one channel he showed me
but yeah he's he's getting to me it's
called Disturbed reality that's the name
of the channel oh yeah I've heard us and
they did a video on there about that
damn dog video
it's a famous dog is that real yeah it's
real [ __ ] are we sure that that's
right well law enforcement was looking
for the dude
Disturbed reality is it it will disturb
your reality and [ __ ] me and Jen
[ __ ] understand that he's real does
that the realities all right it's far
outside normal civilian [ __ ] well
like I said I write about a lot of it so
I know right but it's like if but I'm
also very aware
that sometimes
stuff gets exaggerated harness and stuff
and stuff can be like yeah
um not real and stuff can be con so I'm
just very cognizant
but I'm gonna ask if he's alive if some
[ __ ] like that happened in real life
and I found the person that did that
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] really happened yeah
oh no
I'm not letting you get out of here
alive no
like I said I'm gonna [ __ ] eat your
ass I'm trying to get him back I'm gonna
eat you and [ __ ] you out
shit's not happening
the [ __ ] that you do you do bad [ __ ] to
like babies or children or animals all
right or anything like that murder horn
is coming back home as soon as he's back
on I'm gonna ask you there is no reason
for you to still be in the human race
yeah doing [ __ ] like that all right we
don't need you I'll ask him because
knows more about it I'll get him on it
right now
don't need you all right
he shows up
American Military 100 said well that is
the case where a third world Justice
should be warranted probably I mean yeah
I think that you were talking about but
that's going to be the whole world now
all right that's just the way it is well
I'm just saying that but that's gonna be
the whole but what I'm saying is that
you can't be unless you're entirely
certain
because I'm very aware on the other side
of things that humans in general really
like
black and white Solutions
and I've re I've written and read about
a number of cases where some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happened to somebody
nerd murder Hornet right there in the
middle
that in Mexico
he's coming home
where are you where you you hear murder
horny go ahead
well I forgot what I was saying now ah
shoot
didn't mean to do that to you well you
do though but no no I'm [ __ ] I'm
working here I'm working
yeah me too
but what I was saying was that
I've written about a number of cases
where
everybody was very certain that a
certain person had done things and that
it turned out much later that that
person had not done that
so it's like you can't
jump to conclusions that's what I'm
saying it's like everything is difficult
and I know that like it's very human to
want very simple like black and white
solutions to things but that's usually
not the case okay so you have to be
but murder Hornets is here good you had
to be what you have to be careful about
it you have to be really circumspect
about like especially when somebody's
life is on the line like you can't just
like jump in and say like hey this
person did this that and the other and
we're gonna like Lynch them yeah
um
you don't know if that's necessary all
right hornet on Disturbed reality
there was a video there about the dude
that made the damn snuff flick with the
dog and all her puppies where he's
cutting the puppies open and the mama
dog's eating the [ __ ] puppies and
he's [ __ ] the little [ __ ] puppies
that are cut up when that [ __ ] [ __ ] when
he played that [ __ ] that's it man I
unsubscribed in that channel I could
watch all that [ __ ] [ __ ] with it them
cutting them dudes apart and you know
that that doesn't bother me but there
was something about that one right there
I was like man I don't want to hear
about this thing but
they're saying well did that really
happen
[ __ ]
I got part of the way through that video
and I had to shut that [ __ ] down all
right yeah I'm not watching I I believe
that did happen What was the name of
that video I was I ain't going back to
go look at it all right what was the
name of that case
with those dogs
and uh yeah what country did they think
that that was it was just a video that
they found on some of these [ __ ]
weird sites there's a bunch of weird
[ __ ] evidently happening on Facebook in
private groups that Facebook knows all
about too well
um about dudes paying little boys to
kill animals in these private can I tell
you though right now that
you never know what's real and what's
not because
um from me being somebody that's like
real into the horror [ __ ]
there's a whole
ARG subculture
I don't know if you know about that
um where people are trying to make stuff
appear as real as possible and like not
so I'm always like I'm always skeptical
I'm not saying that like I don't think
that people could do that kind of [ __ ]
because I know that they can I know
people suck okay but
there's also kind of a thing where
people are trying to make things seem
real
but maybe is not real so I don't really
know I'm always kind of like
to be honest I'm always I'm a pessimist
so I'm always just kind of like yeah
people probably do that [ __ ]
but I always like to think maybe people
aren't really doing that and they're
just like pretending just to be Edge
Lords or
because like it's an alternate reality
game they're trying to introduce and
they're trying to be as edgy as possible
so they'll get like some
mileage out of it like some people will
see it I don't know those are the first
two things that I jump to because I'm
hopeful
but
I also know that people are the worst so
you know my third thing is so I was like
well maybe somebody really did do that
because like I said we watched that talk
we all watch that documentary
um it was on Netflix it was called don't
[ __ ] with cats we did a review of it
and
um that dude
I don't even like to say it
he put little kittens in a bag
and sucked out all the air and
videotaped all of it
um so you know
happily the
um I watched the documentary the
documentary didn't show it like it
blurred some things out you know what I
mean it wasn't I could watch it without
getting too like [ __ ] upset about it
what'd he say but well not that I'm
talking okay
um
but you know it's just kind of like I it
makes me happy that
that [ __ ] that did that to those
kittens
um the internet
found that
found that [ __ ] because Jesus
Christ who the [ __ ] would do that who
would do that anybody that would do that
to kittens
well they're looking for would do that
to a person they're looking for that
dude that did that to the dog and all
those [ __ ] puppies that's what I'm
saying
It's like because that's not crazy it's
like I know that people are like oh you
don't give a [ __ ] about what happens to
humans you only give a [ __ ] about what
happens to animals but it's just like
depends on anybody that would do yeah
that's another thing depends on him one
anybody that would do that [ __ ] to like
kittens or puppies or anything like that
um you got some problems and you
probably should be incarcerated just on
General principle yeah two
um anybody that would do that [ __ ] to
animals has probably done bad [ __ ] to
humans also you can't just let those
[ __ ] walk and you can't just
let people like that walk around because
like I said it's like if you're doing
like a kitten they're two different
puppy that's like doing something to a
baby yeah right that's like I kind of
feel like that's kind of equivalent
so we really should not let people like
that be walking around loops
just saying because y'all got some
problems before Mafia said he tried to
watch it I don't know which documentary
you're talking about but for hurting
animals were you talking about which
well probably like um don't [ __ ] with
cats oh yeah which was on that place
yeah yeah we reviewed that yeah
um I had a really hard time watching
that one dude was taking [ __ ] cats
putting them in Ziplocs that's that's
what I was talking about yeah yeah okay
[ __ ] right trying to thinking he's the
[ __ ] gay supermodel watching that
[ __ ] and uh and then he ended up killing
his Chinese boyfriend and can I can I
love the I love that
those videos that he uplit for whatever
reason
um
every bit like people on the internet
were like we're gonna [ __ ] find this
[ __ ] dude yeah and they did they did
they found him they were just like they
were kind of like that building in the
background if they found his
[ __ ] found it but they didn't
find him in time to [ __ ] save that
dude I know and that sucked yeah but at
least they [ __ ] found him yeah
you know just run the background because
Jesus Christ I mean it's just a [ __ ]
common it's just a Common Thread if
they're doing that to animals it's only
a matter of time for they do the people
that's what I'm saying and it's like and
I kind of feel like that's why I don't
think we should make the distinction
between oh my God they're doing stuff to
animals over oh it's so much worse than
others do it it's it's it's along the
same Spectrum yeah and it's not just
killing them they're they're doing
[ __ ] hard they're enjoying it's a set
they're sexualizing it in a way too
right they're me and that's what I'm
saying that's why I don't think it's
that weird I don't think it's that weird
to like say that oh it's a oh it's a
difference between like a puppy or a
kitten or a person it's not really that
much of a distinction because
um anybody that would enjoy
the suffering of a being whether it was
an animal or a person
um
that's somebody you have to yeah we see
things they're not after the animal
they're using the animals to substitute
for a person they want it to be a person
that's what I mean they don't really
have the strength and The Bravery to get
a hold of a person yet but after they
get [ __ ] a couple of animals under
their belts I mean there's a reason why
most serial killers they're just
practicing they say they did like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] to animals like when they were
kids they're just practicing they're
practicing yeah it's it's a build up
yeah and so that's why anytime you see
anybody even if they're a kid I mean if
they're a kid that's old enough to know
better and they're doing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
to animals when they're eight nine ten
years old
yeah I'm not saying kill the kid I'm not
saying that
watch the kid watch that kid murder
comes in and then he disappears
incarcerate that kid do something with
that kid because that is not gonna get
better you really need to like look into
that [ __ ] you really need to look at it
it might not amount to anything
it might not but
you better watch that because any
child that enjoys the suffering of being
that they're not Rickshaw jumps in says
he was Canadian I think they found him
in Germany he must be I don't I don't
have the context I'm assuming that
you're talking about the dude who
[ __ ] did that to that the don't [ __ ]
with cats dude I can't remember what his
name was they didn't find it yeah they
found him in Germany I guess they did I
can't remember it's been a while since
we were talking about we did like talk
about that documentary a while back
yeah then [ __ ] probably shouldn't
plug a channel like Disturbed you know
what are you talking about why not when
we make it demonetize
no I don't think so I mean we might I
don't know
on YouTube sometimes we get demonetized
sometimes we don't yeah yeah so it's all
over that's a YouTube channel it's all
over the place reality is on YouTube it
doesn't show anything
it talks about what's in a video
it might show some stills from it but
they don't really show the video
but they do kind of say where the video
comes from and there's a lot of stuff on
Disturbed reality you know
it's not only serial killer stuff some
of it's kind of stuff that's happening
on battlefields around the world what
actually happens in war
uh some sometimes like execution videos
where guys are executing people from the
other side of some kind of conflict that
they're in
I mean one of the worst videos I've ever
I've ever seen was
probably around in 1997 in the early
internet phase they had a of site called
Gore Gallery I remember that remember
that one was mostly Stills yeah we had a
[ __ ] little video that they'd upload
there and I think it might have been
somewhere up in Bosnia or Bosnia or
Herzegovina it looked Eastern European
or some guys in
military uniforms
it looked Eastern European to me they
had a guy tied to a chair and they're
[ __ ] yelling at him they kicked that
chair over onto its side
and if God jumps onto him and another
dude with the video camera zooms into
the guy's face and the guy takes a damn
AK-47 bayonet that puts it on his Temple
right around here and and just shoves
that knife through that dude's head
to the side some kind of execution
and he screams the whole [ __ ] time
and they're showing his face
dude knew he was dying that one was
[ __ ] I was like oh God and I was
young and [ __ ] stronger back then
[ __ ] I felt I had a stronger
resistance I was watching that
still and that still shook me I was like
God well I hope so yeah it was like that
was the [ __ ] word like I said I like
horror movies and [ __ ] but the second
you like start showing me real [ __ ] that
[ __ ] went right through that dude's
[ __ ] frontal lobes he could hear it
[ __ ] like I can watch it but I don't
like it you could hear it crunch as it
went through that dude's bones
and he screamed the whole time I don't
know what he did
I couldn't understand what language it
was it was some kind of Cyrillic
language
they felt he deserved it that he had
done something bad yeah but maybe he did
but yeah but maybe not
maybe he didn't do anything like from
our point I don't know well it was more
than one military dude there they
thought he did something
he did something and it was Battlefield
Justice some kind of a [ __ ] uh it was
some kind of a
summary execution
but they didn't waste a bullet on him
they felt he deserved a [ __ ] bayonet
through the head see like I said I don't
I don't know it could have been anything
maybe he raped and killed some [ __ ]
girl yeah but maybe he did you don't
know I don't know what they said that's
what I'm saying I don't know what they
said they were saying it was like I
don't know how I feel about it I think
it's just like I don't really know I can
tell from the demeanor of the dudes that
did it they felt he deserved it
that I don't know what it was yeah but
you don't know no I don't know like the
people that it was between them felt
like he deserved it could have been
worse than he was I wasn't there to
judge it wasn't my country all right it
wasn't it wasn't a war I was involved in
they felt he deserved it
wait I saw something uh yeah Luke
Magnolia men well yeah what was this
last name men
Yola or something like that yeah the cat
dude yeah mango said I think his name
was [ __ ] hater he did not like cats
what a wanker yeah I mean that
[ __ ]
like look I love cats okay so it's like
the second you do something bad to cats
he thought he was the world's greatest
we're gonna have a problem we thought he
was the world's greatest like don't do
bad [ __ ] to people either obviously but
it's like
especially don't do anything I thought
it was the world's greatest prettiest
[ __ ] gay porn star
but he's got to go kill cats and hang
out with girls that was some weird [ __ ]
that dude was [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like I don't understand
why like
his particular case that documentary
um
I don't know like I I wasn't sure if I
wanted it's a good documentary you
should watch it like they show like bad
[ __ ] but they you know kind of blur
everything out so I wasn't there wasn't
anything in there that I couldn't watch
but
I don't understand how you would get to
a mental place
where you would make little fuzzy
adorable little creatures why would you
make them suffer for whatever your
[ __ ] ego problem was
yeah like maybe you should go to a
therapist and deal with that [ __ ] how
long
three hours okay it's time for us to
[ __ ] shut it down anyway hold on I
got to like some other things I got to
answer but I'm just saying that it's
like
I I can't imagine a single situation
where making a tiny little fuzzy cute
animal suffer would make anything better
I can't imagine Larry just jumps his I'm
just jumping in now at the end of the
show [ __ ] everybody's High I guess I
missed it kind of a deal and I'm like
yeah Larry says cats can't ever do wrong
they can't like I said that's what I
mean I love I'm an animal lover it's
like we have a couple of cats and it's
just kind of like I can't imagine any
situation where
that would make anything better it's
time for me to shut this [ __ ] down
Jenny [ __ ] even even [ __ ] Oscars
say shut this [ __ ] down we're gonna
shut it down well he said that a long
time yeah but yeah I ain't worried about
you I'll ask her okay
but we've been on for three hours so
time for the [ __ ] to shoot down and
justice for me so that's how the Iceman
Richard Kuklinski yeah it started
killing animals so we all know how wait
he went on to do well yeah a lot of
serial killers not all of them but um a
very large percentage they start out
torturing animals like I said you take a
helpless
animal
and make it suffer for your enjoyment
that's never a good sign never a good
sign I'm not saying that everybody that
does that as a kid like uh turns out a
serial killer because they don't but
it's not a good sign that kid at least
needs therapy because that's
that's a problem that's a big problem
because I literally I never felt like
that Tom never felt like that most
normal people 99 of normal people
do not
get enjoyment out of the suffering of
innocent animals or people when they are
children so if you have a situation like
that get that kid into therapy ASAP
because
there are some problems there are some
problems there all right so we are gonna
knock it off for the evening
hopefully you guys had a good time we
had a good time talking about whatever
the [ __ ] we talked about for the last
three hours I don't even remember
but you know we'll be back on Sunday
talking about a movie which if you're
not a patron you should probably go over
there and be a patron and then you can
vote on what movies we talk about on our
live streams on Sunday and Tuesday
so I've got a poll up I think it's gonna
go up tomorrow
where you can vote on the on the movie
that we're going to be talking about on
Sunday
so we'll be back on Sunday talking about
a movie yeah right
no I'm hungry you want uh you want some
pizza
sure I got pizza it's got black olives
on it though you're gonna be making so
many [ __ ] black olives on it I put
black olives on a whole [ __ ] Pizza
why'd you do that because I wasn't
thinking I just put black olives on the
pizza Jenny does not like black olives
you could pull the black olives out like
you did last time I guess I'm gonna have
to do that all right make you something
else no I can make you something I got
ramen
want some Ramen that sounds better right
okay I'm making some Ramen all right so
we'll be back on Sunday talking about a
movie we don't know which one yet
because we have to wait until see what
everybody votes for thank you for
dropping by thank you for your super
chats we will see you guys on Sunday
afternoon have a good weekend
good night
[Music]